voilà bonjour à toutes et à tous madame
nous accueillons cet après-midi
pour la poursuite de nos travaux de la
commission d'enquête visant à établir
les raisons de la paire de souveraineté
d'indépendance
énergétique de la France madame cosucco
Morizet normalement elle nous entend
puisqu'elle est présente en visio
formidable j'en ai devant moi depuis New
York ou ses nouvelles activités
l'ont conduites
nous vous remercions Madame
Kosciusko-Morizet d'avoir accepté de
participer à nos travaux malgré la
distance et de venir témoigner de vos
fonctions ministérielles passées dans le
domaine de l'écologie nous remercions
d'accepter cet échange depuis les
États-Unis malgré le décalage horaire
qui fait il me semble qu'il est beaucoup
plus tôt chez vous que chez nous
au cours d'audition précédente nous
avons évidemment parlé des sujets
français
l'inflation réduction Act a également
été évoqué
laissant
rêveur ou songeur en fonction des points
de vue qu'il s'agisse de relocalisation
de transition énergétique ou bien
parfois d'ajustements budgétaire voilà
des sujets qui ont aussi un petit peu
illustrés nos travaux peut-être que
votre position nous permettra de
l'aborder en marge de nos échanges la
commission d'enquête que l'honneur de
présidé tente de comprendre le processus
de décision
aboutissant à la définition d'une
politique énergétique à ses objectifs au
degré de prise en compte de son
caractère stratégique pour la
souveraineté et l'indépendance d'un pays
comme la France
nous voulions pouvoir vous entendre
partager avec nous votre expérience dans
ce domaine la répartition des
attributions ministérielles entraînant
parfois des enchevêtrement de
compétences complexes à démêler
aussi bien après coup que dans
l'exercice j'imagine nous avons ainsi
appris comment évoluer la compétence en
matière minière et comment un
observatoire peut en remplacer un autre
créer 12 ans plus tôt je pense là au
comité pour les métostratégiques
institué par décret en 2011 or vous avez
géré une partie du dossier complexe du
gaz de schiste et ouvert le chantier de
la réforme du code minier en votre temps
vous avez aussi participé à la mise en
oeuvre du Grenelle de l'environnement
nous avions à ce titre auditionné la
semaine dernière Jean-Louis Borloo
lorsque vous étiez député vous avez
observé le kilowatt-heure le moins cher
qui était celui que l'on que l'on
consommait pas et vous avez aussi
considéré que les réacteurs à neutrons
rapides répondaient à une logique
écologique
pouvez-vous ainsi madame la ministre
nous indiquer la place et le rôle
de la secrétaire d'État que vous avez
été ou la ministre chargée de l'écologie
dans un dans la définition des
politiques publiques relatives à
l'énergie avant de vous laisser la
parole pour un exposé liminaire il me
revient de vous demander de bien vouloir
prêter serment de dire la vérité toute
la vérité rien que la vérité en
application des textes qui régissent la
vie parlementaire voilà je vous préviens
vouloir vous pièces formalisme et puis
je vous laisserai la parole
je te le jure merci beaucoup et bien je
vous laisse la parole pour un propos
liminaire on va regarder tout droit on
vous voit aussi ici
le Président Monsieur rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les députés pour
pour votre invitation et merci pour la
souplesse qui permet de le faire en zoom
les semaines pendant lesquelles vous
auditionnez des semaines pendant
lesquelles je ne venais pas à Paris ce
qui m'arrive quand même de temps en
temps mais même pas celle-ci j'ai reçu
un questionnaire pour orienter le propos
liminaire donc j'ai pris bonne note des
questions de la commission je vais
t'acheter d'y répondre
à charge pour vous peut-être de
prolonger par des questions si mes
réponses ne
touchez pas complètement la cible
l'essentiel de mon activité comme
secrétaire d'État puis communiste sur
les questions énergétiques c'est
organisées autour de trois pôles que
vous avez esquissé dans votre propre
polymère le grenade de l'environnement
en effet donc d'abord ça conception et
sa négociation quand j'étais secrétaire
d'État en 2007-2008 et puis ensuite sa
mise en œuvre quand j'étais ministre
entre 2010 et 2012
l'accident de Fukushima et la gestion de
ses suites comme ministre en charge de
la sûreté nucléaire entre 2017 et 2012
et puis d'autres sujets des sujets de
politique énergétiques qui comportaient
de manière évidente une dimension
environnementale majeure comme le gaz de
schiste que vous avez évoqué entre 2006
et 2012 je prie ça parce que
certains sujets d'intérêt pour la
Commission ne relevez pas ou pas
totalement mais attributions par exemple
le nucléaire comme la chasse avait été
sorti du champ du Grenelle ce qui veut
pas dire que c'est une c'est un fait que
le nucléaire fait partie du paysage
énergétique français mais il avait été
décidé et accepté qui aurait pas de
groupes de négociation en tant que tel
sur le nucléaire dans le Grenelle le
l'environnement
et par ailleurs après en 2010 quand j'ai
repris le grand ministère toute la
dimension marché d'énergie a été
rattaché à Bercy pour des raisons qui
d'ailleurs sont pas sans rapport avec
les travaux de votre donc concrètement
si on s'intéresse au nucléaire je me
suis occupé du nucléaire sous l'angle de
la sûreté
comme ministre et en dehors du Grenelle
ça n'empêche pas d'avoir un point de vue
personnel sur certaines des questions
qui ont été abordées par votre
commission mais je croisais de préciser
qu'elles étaient pas pour certaines
totalement dans mon champ ministériel
donc je vais reprendre si vous voulez
bien les les trois angles que je
décrivais qui sont ceux par lesquels
j'ai abordé les politiques énergétiques
en commençant par le Grenelle
j'en parle avec certaines légitimités si
vous permettez parce que j'ai conçu le
projet dans la campagne de Nicolas
Sarkozy en fait en 2006
à l'époque on a choisi le nom qui a une
quête de légitimation que je ressentais
dans les milieux de ONG que je
fréquentais une quête de légitimation
que je trouvais par ailleurs recevable
les ONG aspiraient à avoir un statut qui
soit l'équivalent de celui des syndicats
et
et c'est la convergence entre cette
demande et le désir de lancer un grand
programme de transformation écologique
qui a abouti au projet du Grenelle de
l'environnement et notamment à ce
nombre-là donc il rappelait enfin de
manière explicite des accords de
Grenelle
c'est aussi en écho à cette demande de
légitimation qui ont été conçues
d'autres mesures que vous trouviez dans
la campagne du candidat et futur
président par exemple la transformation
du Conseil économique et social en
Conseil économique social et
environnemental
donc voilà je me suis occupé de la
conception du projet comme comme
responsable de l'environnement en fait
dans la campagne du candidat je me suis
occupé de sa négociation
comme secrétaire d'État essentiellement
à l'automne 2016 et puis finalement
quand je suis revenu au ministère en
2010 j'ai mené une partie de sa mise en
oeuvre puisqu'à l'époque les lois
Grenelle avait été votées mais il
restait largement à sortir toute la
partie réglementaire et puis il y avait
il y avait toutes sortes de choses qui
étaient par ailleurs non législatives ou
réglementaire qu'il fallait tout
simplement directement mettre en oeuvre
j'en parle avec une petite légitimité
j'en parle aussi avec une certaine
passion parce que je reste persuadé plus
de 10 ans après que nous avons façonné
une démarche qui était à la fois
innovante et
utile et qui a permis de déchirer
quelques-uns de ces corsets dans lequel
on enferme ou s'enferme se trouve
enfermés les politiques publiques de
sortir un certain nombre d'acteurs de
leur postures ça leur faisait du bien ça
faisait du bien à tout le monde et tout
ça je crois pour le meilleur bénéfice
des politiques environnementales et même
du pays la méthode du Grenelle c'est de
mettre tout le monde autour de la table
dans des collèges on a pris des collèges
les ONG l'État les élus les entreprises
les syndicats et s'accorder sur des
politiques coopératives qui dépassent
les querelles historiques c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles on avait
d'emblée sortie certains sujets du
Grenelle je citais le nucléaire la
chasse et les OGM parce qu'on savait
qu'en fait il était
peu probable qu'on parvienne à des
politiques coopératives sur le sur le
sujet
les questions énergétiques dans Grenelle
était plus particulièrement traitée par
le groupe 1 les donc les négociations
étaient réparties étaient entre
différents groupes de travail auxquels
participaient tous les collèges que j'ai
cités donc le groupe a s'appelait lutter
contre les changements climatiques et
maîtriser la demande d'énergie il y
avait les ateliers à l'intérieur de ce
groupe il y avait l'atelier transport il
y avait l'atelier urbanisme bâtiment il
y avait l'atelier production et stockage
je cite ce fait parce que je pense que
le seul titre de ce groupe 1 répond en
creux à certaines de la Commission à
certaines des questions de la Commission
pour la période
2007-2012 pendant laquelle l'efficacité
énergétique et la maîtrise de la
consommation ont été sur le devant de la
scène et en tout cas au cœur des travaux
du Grenelle
ce qui veut pas dire je reviendrai qu'on
a pas parlé ou travailler sur la
production mais enfin c'était en quelque
sorte de seconde on a fait beaucoup sur
le sujet de l'efficacité énergétique
dans le cadre de ce groupe que j'ai cité
comme dans le cadre d'ailleurs des
groupes transports des groupes bâtiments
citer quelques mesures qui rappelleront
des souvenirs peut-être pour dresser un
peu la scène le bonus malus sur les
véhicules individuels les quotas sur le
transport routier qui était
une chose qu'elle fait beaucoup
travaillé qui a malheureusement été
abandonné par la suite pour de très
mauvaises raisons que je déplore
la nouvelle réglementation thermique sur
les bâtiments les coprais sur le
logement social citez que quelques
mesures structurantes qui ont été
conçu et mise en œuvre dans cette
période de 5 ans
parmi toutes ces mesures d'efficacité
énergétique il y en a quelques-unes qui
concernent de plus près l'objet de votre
commission d'une certaine manière toutes
les mesures qui ont un impact sur
l'efficacité énergétique me semble
permisante en fait pour votre objet mais
la quelques-unes qui ont probablement un
impact plus nette et elles ont souvent
été portées par l'ADEME on a profité du
Grenelle de l'environnement pour
revivifier un peu la dame lui donner une
direction je parle pas de personne je
parle de direction sans de d'orientation
stratégique lui donner une orientation
stratégique plus claire et lui donner
des nouveaux moyens je vais en citer
trois le fond démonstrateur
qui donc c'était quelque chose qui qui
existait sous une forme
il y avait un embryon de ça mais c'était
50 millions en 2008 c'est passé à 400
millions sur
4 ans et c'était dessiné destiné à faire
passer à la phase d'industrialisation
des innovations donc notamment certaines
dans le domaine énergétique
on a lancé le fond chaleur qui lui
n'existait pas il y avait carrément pas
d'embryon de ça avec un milliard sur la
période
2009-2011 à fond largement destiné aux
entreprises pour développer la chaleur
renouvelable et réseaux de chaleur la
valorisation de la biomasse
on a relancé le fond déchet et surtout
on la réorienté parce que il était
essentiellement consacré à l'aide aux
incinérateurs et on la réorienté vers
des projets qui faisaient meilleurs
place au recyclage alors encore une fois
tout ça signifie pas qu'on sait pas
occupé de production d'énergie dans le
Grenelle mais le sujet venait clairement
après une
objective affiché qui était d'abord de
se concentrer sur la maîtrise de la de
la consommation en matière de production
donc on a quand même parler
on a visé un doublement de la part des
ENR d'ici 2020 comme vous savez un
doublement c'est en fait très ambitieux
parce que si on tous ces calculs
prennent en compte la part de
l'hydroélectricité donc donc c'est un
beau plus que doublement des énergies
renouvelables non
hors hydroélectricité
si on rentre dans le détail de ce
doublement et avait la multiplication
par deux du bois énergie il y avait
beaucoup de choses sur les réseaux de
chaleur
il y avait bien sûr du photovoltaïque un
quart de tout ça devait passer par le
fond chaleur donc j'ai parlé précisément
et par exemple on multiplier par 5 les
compléments qui étaient adoptés aux
contrat de plan est à ta région donc il
y avait des aides
puissantes sur ce sur ce sujet il y
avait aussi des mesures non directement
financière budgétaire des par exemple on
avait on a étendu à toutes les
collectivités et plus seulement aux
communes la possibilité de bénéficier du
tarif de rachat d'énergie renouvelable
alors ça a l'air de rien mais ça
permettait comme vous savez de faire
entrer les collèges les lycées ce genre
de
d'institutions dans le champ de cette
nouvelle politique publique
de d'aborder une dimension qui a
véritablement fait mon obsession à moi
en tout cas lors du Grenelle de
l'environnement tout au long du Grenelle
et d'ailleurs au-delà du Grenelle dans
l'ensemble de ma pratique ministérielle
et dont j'ai l'impression qu'elle a été
peu présente dans vos travaux ce que je
peux comprendre d'ailleurs parce que
c'est pas même si je trouve que même si
je trouve que c'est important que ça
devrait avoir une place
comme par ailleurs l'efficacité
énergétique et il s'agit du coup de
plage des objectifs environnementaux
avec la politique en faveur de l'emploi
comme du couplage de la politique
énergétique avec la politique
industrielle ou avec ce qu'il en reste
si je me réfère au titre de votre
commission et je crois que ça a été
évoqué l'indépendance énergétique
stricto sensus et
sans doute inatteignable enfin c'est
quelque chose un peu un peu d'un peu
fantasmé la souveraineté un concept
important c'est un concept un peu
subjectif et qu'un concept qui est
fortement corrélé avec d'autres
dimensions comme la compétitivité et je
crois important dans tout ça que les
politiques énergétiques qui sont
tellement centrales dans une économie et
un sens un sens
et au-delà de de celui qu'on cherche ici
un sens économique social industriel et
comme je le disais ça a été mon
obsession dans le Grenelle au-delà des
objectifs environnementaux
tisser des liens et c'était c'était
c'était cohérent avec ce que je
décrivais tout à l'heure de mettre tous
les collèges autour de la table les
syndicats les entreprises c'était pas
juste une série de mesures
environnementales c'était une politique
globale qui sait des liens vers
l'économie vers le social vers d'autres
dimensions et on a eu des réussites en
la matière par exemple les 10000 emplois
créés par le fond chaleur et à ce titre
je suis particulièrement fier de la
politique en faveur de l'éolien en mer
que j'ai lancé de mémoire au début 2011
franchement de la moquerie générale à
l'époque
alors maintenant comme les beaux bébés
elle a beaucoup de peurs vendiquées et
je pense qu'elle est intéressante parce
que elle signifie encre d'autres échecs
d'autres politiques qui ont été qui ont
été moins faciles ce qu'on a fait pour
l'éolien en mer c'est qu'on a fait des
appels d'offres très travaillées
sur lesquels la Commission européenne a
largement fermé les yeux
on a intégré des critères de production
locale sur lesquelles la France a tenu
bon et on a réussi à travers ça à
développer une vraie base de production
française et européenne une vraie une
vraie industrie de production locale je
disais que c'est important parce que il
y a d'autres sujets sur lesquels on a eu
moins de succès par exemple sur l'éolien
terrestre sur les gens sur l'éolien
terrestre probablement puisqu'on partait
plus tard que les volumes français
étaient faibles au regard du marché
européen
sur les Allemands et les Danois qui ont
été les grands bénéficiaires de
de la monter en puissance de l'éolien
terrestre en terme industrielle sur le
soleil
on a fait le moratoire moi j'ai fait le
moratoire
pour des raisons financières comme tous
les États
européens mais aussi pour des raisons
industrielles parce qu'en fait
tel qu'elle avait été mise en place la
politique en faveur du soleil était
beaucoup de subventions
payer largement sur les générations
futures parce que c'était des
subventions c'était un cadre de
subventions dans le long terme
qui profitait à des emplois qui étaient
seulement des emplois d'installation et
maintenant et sans base sans
développement d'une base industrielle
puisque c'était largement et même de
plus en plus des panneaux importés donc
on a remis ça à plat on a remis ça à
plat en faisant des appels d'offres avec
des critères bas carbone pour favoriser
la production locale on a même mis en
place un critère de bilan carbone pour
essayer de contourner les règles de
l'organisation mondial du commerce et de
limiter les importations de panneaux
chinois et d'essayer de booster un peu
l'industrie nationale donc on prenait en
compte dans l'évaluation du bilan
carbone d'un champ solaire on prenait en
compte
le l'impact carbone par exemple la
production mais aussi du transport de
ces panneaux depuis sa base de
production c'est à moins bien marché que
pour l'éolien en mer
et j'ai vu
j'ai regardé enfin au fil des années
j'ai vu que les appels d'offres en fait
se faisaient de plus en plus sens ces
critères bas carbone
j'étais plus en charge mais les gens
auxquels j'en ai parlé m'ont dit que la
Commission européenne avait été très
dure sur ce sujet probablement plusieurs
raisons l'éolien en mer c'est plus gros
donc c'est plus facile d'avoir des
critères de localisation des justifiés
il y a un critère de maturité l'éolien
en mer c'était émergent la Commission
européenne a été sensible à l'argument
émergent on a besoin d'avoir une base
locale et puis en bénéficier aussi la
géographie puisqu'on a un plateau
continental très plat et donc il y avait
il y avait une il y avait un sens
particulier à développer une industrie
nationale disons de l'éolien en mergenot
d'ailleurs qu'on est en train de
poursuivre la même voie que celle qu'on
a engagé sur l'éolien en mer avec
l'éolien flottant ce qui est ce qui est
bien si c'était confirmé
votre questionnaire comportait une
question spécifique sur les
investissements dans la recherche et
dans les énergies renouvelables
il y a deux poches d'investissement qui
me semble pertinentes pour répondre à
cette question
d'abord dans le cadre du Grenelle de
l'environnement alors c'est assez
curieux mais dans le cadre du Grenelle
de l'environnement
en matière d'énergie
l'essentiel des crédits
vraiment des crédits des crédits directs
je parle pas des appels d'offres qu'on a
lancé après des politiques de soutien
aux énergies renouvelables mais
l'essentiel des tissusions directes sont
allés au nucléaire
précisément au projet Astrid
au réacteur eurovis il y a eu un petit
peu sur les déchets radioactifs je crois
qu'il y a eu un petit peu sur landra les
méthodes innovantes de
gestion de déchets peut-être un petit
peu sur l'IRSN enfin c'était un milliard
en tout et en matière de
d'investissement dans la recherche
d'investissement direct dans la
recherche c'était pour l'essentiel
de la recherche en matière de nucléaire
je disais qu'on peut considérer que
c'est une bizarrerie parce que j'ai dit
plutôt que Leclerc faisait pas partie du
Grenelle le nucléaire faisait pas partie
des sujets négociations de Grenelle mais
les programmes d'investissement
eux-mêmes étaient des programmes publics
qui ont pas à proprement parler jamais
été discuté dans les groupes de travail
qui était plutôt voilà des choix
consulaires de l'État
ce qui explique cette particularité il y
a eu des choses hors nucléaires en
matière de
recherche néanmoins dans le grenade j'ai
cités par ailleurs le fond des monstres
par exemple font des démonstrateurs de
l'ADEME dans lequel il y avait des
projets d'énergie nouvelle et puis je me
suis personnellement occupé de
d'investissement dans la recherche et en
dehors du Grenelle
par exemple à travers le programme le
paysage programme d'investissement
d'avenir dans lequel on a fait à
l'époque de l'économie circulaire on a
fait des démonstrateurs sur les smart
grid les batteries les procédés
industriels moins polluants comme la
récupération de auto la récupération de
chaleur des constructions performantes
énergétiquement en fait on a fait
beaucoup de choses dans le cas du
paysage sur les économies d'énergie
ce que je crois qu'après ça a été un
petit peu réorienté justement il y a eu
plus d'éolien en mer il y a eu plus de
flotteurs il y a plus d'hydrogène mais à
l'époque les moyens du pays a en matière
énergétique était était en cohérence
d'ailleurs avec ce qu'on faisait avec le
Grenelle assez fortement orienté sur la
l'efficacité énergétique
je vais parler ici tout ce qui dans le
Grenelle me semblait pertinent pour
répondre à vos questions comme j'ai dit
en introduction la régulation du marché
les grands opérateurs de l'énergie
n'étaient pas de morceaux ce qui veut
pas dire que j'ai pas interagi avec eux
mais
avec d'autres lentilles et notamment sur
la question de la production et
des nouveaux carburants et des sur
celles du gaz de schiste
donc c'est un deuxième deuxième volet et
vous l'avez signalé
conséquemment aux travaux sur le gaz de
schiste le lancement de la réforme du
code minier
je suis intervenu sur le gaz de schiste
vraiment avec la casquette
environnementale
considérant que les conditions
d'exploitation à l'époque remplissaient
pas nos critères de qualité qui posaient
aussi des problèmes propres à notre
géographie je vais pas vous refaire les
débats de l'époque qui ont été assez
denses et agité mais il y avait à la
fois donc des des critères
environnementaux beaucoup de d'arguments
autour de la protection des nappes
phréatiques autour de la protection des
ressources en eau je considère
d'ailleurs que les récentes évolutions
sur le front de la ressource en eau nous
donne totalement raison si certains
avaient un doute et donc ça ça a été des
motifs pour suspendre en fait annuler
les
permis sur le gaz de schiste et puis et
puis suivre ces cas-là on s'est rendu
compte que c'est permis avait été donné
dans les conditions qui étaient certes
légales mais étaient quand même
problématique au regard des
nouvelles exigences de l'esprit du
Grenelle par exemple en matière de de
transparence parce que le code minier
procédait de logique qui était qui était
qui était ancienne à cet égard et donc
on a c'est une réforme du code minier
pour finir pardon mais pour finir donc
je vous ai parlé du Grenelle de
l'environnement je vous ai parlé le
sujet énergétique orgrenelle par exemple
le gaz de schiste et la réforme du code
minier pour finir je peux vous dire un
mot
en réponse à vos questions sur la sûreté
nucléaire et sur les conséquences de
l'accident de Fukushima alors pour le
coup c'est des sujets sont des sujets
qui relevaient totalement les
attributions dans la période 2010 2012
totalement et exclusivement
donc l'accident de Fukushima a eu lieu
en mars 2011
il a il a suscité un certain nombre de
réactions
dans
de réflexion sur sa prise en compte ce
qui est tout à fait normal c'est normal
et sain qu'un accident appelle un retour
d'expérience et éventuellement un
ajustement et d'ailleurs c'est pas la
première fois la création de l'Autorité
de Sûreté Nucléaire la SN dans sa forme
actuelle a été une conséquence tardive
de Tchernobyl et de tous les débats et
même les polémiques qui ont suivi
Tchernobyl
après l'accident de Fukushima
c'est pas tant la gouvernance comme
comme ça avait été le cas pour
tchernobylsounet il y avait eu tous des
bas sur
la transparence en fait sur la
communication
aux populations après de tchernoby après
l'accident de Fukushima c'est pas
tellement là qu'il y a eu
polémique des bas et et finalement c'est
pas la gouvernance qui a réclamé un
ajustement et de fait d'ailleurs
l'accident de Fukushima a mis en
évidence le contraste entre le système
français et la situation japonaise ou la
société était de co qui était
exploitante du site était totalement
imbriquée dans les rouages de l'État et
de la sûreté moi ça m'avait énormément
frappé lors d'un voyage que j'ai fait
quelques semaines après l'accident de
Fukushima pour rencontrer les homologues
c'est vraiment une abrégation complète
entre production sûreté et puissance
publique gouvernementale donc
l'accident d'une certaine manière a mis
en reflet par un ayant lumière par
contraste
la validité du système français qui
avait été reconstruit après enfin
modifié après après Tchernobyl d'une
autorité
totalement indépendante
une chaîne de décision très très
structuré donc rien de spécifique va pas
de remise en cause fondamentale sur la
gouvernance en revanche des réflexions
sur des mesures techniques mais un peu
technique puisque que un public
substantiel que ça le mot technique est
peut-être un peu faible
notamment liés à la notion sur Accident
puisque l'accident de Fukushima c'est ça
c'est l'histoire d'un d'un accident qui
entraîne un autre accident et de
d'accidents qui s'enchaînent les uns les
autres
la notion de sur accident et la notion
du coût de management dans le temps de
Madame de gestion dans le temps de
de la dynamique
de d'un accident donc concrètement ce
qu'on a fait après l'accident de
Fukushima
et une analyse qu'on a essayé d'avoir le
plus complexe rapide sur la base
d'information qu'on avait qui était pas
c'est pas très facile parce que les la
transparence qui est quand même loin
d'être
parfait tout aussi accidents
concrètement ce qu'on a fait c'est que
j'ai demandé à très vite à l'Autorité de
Sûreté Nucléaire
des stress test qu'on a appelé les
évaluations complémentaires de sécurité
c'est c'est complètement différent de de
d'un sujet qui soit fait
l'objet d'une partie de vos débats
des visites décennales évidemment
d'ailleurs à l'époque on avait déjà
lancé le travail sur le cahier des
charges pour les visites décennales y
compris les améliorations planifiées et
ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas une prise
en compte
dans la dans le travail sur les visites
décennales par la suite du retour
d'expérience de l'accident de Fukushima
mais mais disons que il y a il y a deux
il y a des temps différents donc il y a
eu un temps de réponse à la crise de
réponse rapide qui a été juste après
l'accident de demander des stress test
la façon ça c'est fait c'est que
l'Autorité de sûreté nucléaire a produit
un cahier des charges
qui était très directement ciblée sur
l'accident et qui appelait à tirer les
conséquences de l'accident donc dans ce
cahier des charges
parlait inondation tremblement de terre
perte d'approvision électrique
dans une configuration d'accidents quel
qu'en soit l'origine au niveau d'un site
de production nucléaire management
d'opérationnel de la crise
et donc l'ASN a produit un cahier des
charges qui qui autour de ces notions là
l'opérateur EDF a été chargé de mener
des stressations la base de ce cahier
des charges c'est stress test ont été
c'est évaluations étaient rendus
rapidement
à l'automne 2011 et ont provoqué un
train de mesure destiné à accroître la
robustesse de notre dispositif en
situation de crise donc certaines très
évidentes comme par exemple un
générateur diesel pas réacteur
résistant résistance ça veut dire
mis dans des ingénieries particulières
en fait
pour qu'il soit résistant à certaines
certains types de tremblements de terre
d'inondation de tornades
la duplication des stockages d'eau pour
les plus gros réacteurs du parc
le renforcement des piscines vous savez
dans lesquelles on stocke les déchets
sur site qui avaient été un des
problèmes à Fukushima et ça c'était des
mesures techniques rapides et puis il y
en avait d'autres qui étaient peut-être
un petit peu plus sophistiqués et qui
visait à tirer les conséquences de ce
qui avait été l'enchaînement l'accident
de Fukushima dans la durée par exemple
la mise en place de forces projetées
qu'on a appelé les Farnes les forces
d'action rapide du nucléaire ça c'était
une conséquence de ce qu'on avait vu à
Fukushima qui était que sur le site les
opérateurs se retrouvaient isolés
coupés du monde et il y avait il y avait
pas vraiment de
il y avait il y avait pas de commando de
d'ingénierie
d'urgence capables de venir les
renforcer enfin tout ça a été pas été
pas vraiment organisé anticipé on a
aussi demandé des constructions plus
résistantes pour les équipes qui gèrent
l'accident sur le site ça aussi c'est
une conséquence directe de Fukushima un
des problèmes c'est que les opérateurs
qui sont restés sur le site se sont
retrouvés très exposées parce que
la toute cette partie là en fait la
gestion dans la durée de l'accident
avait pas été bien bien conçu ça c'était
au niveau national on a aussi lancé une
revue par les pairs en Europe et puis je
disais on avait avant lancé la
conception du cahier des charges de la
des visites décennales et donc il y a eu
par la suite l'insertion dans les revues
décennales de nouvelles prescriptions et
j'en finis par là c'est une différence
intéressante entre la doctrine en
matière de sûreté nucléaire et d'autres
pays par exemple aux États-Unis ils font
pas ça nous en France on considère que
la
qu'on doit pouvoir améliorer au fil du
temps et du progrès technologique le
niveau de sûreté nucléaire y compris
pour un réacteur existant donc par
exemple les visites des Sénats prévoient
la mise à niveau d'un réacteur
dans la mesure du possible avec un
niveau sûreté au plus proche de ce qu'on
pourrait attendre d'une troisième
génération alors même qu'on parle de
réacteurs de deuxième génération
souligne parce que c'est un choix
c'est un choix une seule manière là ça
va au-delà de la question technique il y
a une dimension politique dans le choix
aux États-Unis ils font pas ça comme ça
aux États-Unis leur visite c'est le
maintien d'un niveau de sûreté qui était
prévu au moment du lancement
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
aucune difficulté sur la durée du propos
liminaire bien au contraire je crois que
c'est ce qui nous permet aussi d'entrer
dans dans le sujet et dans la période
pendant laquelle vous avez exercé vos
responsabilités j'aurais du coup une
première
série de questions qui est vraiment
propre au Grenelle avec un sujet que
vous avez abordé qui était finalement de
ce que je comprends de vos propos
liminaires quasiment un objectif du
Grenelle c'est à dire de mettre autour
de la table et de légitimer dans le tour
de table des acteurs qui jusque là
n'étaient pas forcément dans les
institutions publiques donc les ONG
environnementales
on pourra tout à l'heure parler de leurs
qualification
c'est quelque chose que
les syndicats ont abordé lorsque nous
les avons auditionnés
avec une forme de regret non pas en
regrettant leur position dans le tour de
table mais en soulignant la différence
qu'il y avait entre des syndicats qui
doivent faire preuve la preuve de leur
représentativité avant d'être dans le
tour de table et des ONG qui finalement
sont là
peut-être un peu par une logique plus
arbitraire est-ce que vous avez un point
de vue de ce point de vue là peut-être
de la raison pour laquelle ça s'est fait
comme ça et de des éventuels correctifs
qu'il faudrait qu'il faudrait apporter
alors je comprends très bien le propos
et
c'est c'est
un choix politique qui a été fait
de de
faire monter en quelque sorte
les ONG environnementales à un nouveau
niveau légitimité qu'il n'avait jamais
atteint ça c'était notre choix politique
et du côté des ONG environnementales il
y avait explicitement la demande d'être
pris en compte de la même manière que
les syndicats c'est vraiment ce que ce
que vous dites est tout à fait tout à
fait juste c'est ce que disent les
syndicats et tout à fait juste et
d'ailleurs il y a eu des tensions y
compris à l'époque des tensions assez
explicites parce que c'est une
revendication des ONG d'être considéré
considérés et concurrence de la
considération vous voyez de la même de
la même manière que les syndicats d'être
consultés alors ça prenait d'ailleurs
une variété de forme cette espèce de
revendication il y avait une dimension
très symbolique on voudrait être
officiellement consulter quand il y a
comme dans une négociation sociale
il y avait des dimensions quasiment plus
logistiques avec des ONG qui disaient
mais attendez nous on n'a pas on n'a pas
de moyens on n'a pas tous les systèmes
les comités d'entreprises des machins on
nous demande de venir pour discuter à
Paris dans tel ou telle consultation on
nous des frais même pas on n'a pas de
perdre il y avait il y avait vraiment
toute une variété de de de
d'arguments plus ou moins
plus ou moins substantielle et plus ou
moins relevé mais mais oui la demande
était explicitement d'être
mais aussi considérer comme un syndicat
et le mot Grenelle faisait écho
totalement
explicitement à cette demande là il y a
une ONG qui a été très
pardon j'ai un peu de franglais dans la
tête je vais dire instrumental c'est pas
du tout Français qui a eu qui a tenu une
place importante dans la conception du
Grenelle de l'environnement dans le
choix du mot Grenelle pendant la
campagne de 2006 2016 elle s'appelait
écologie sans frontières c'est une toute
petite ONG avec des leaders qui avaient
une vision très politique de la de la
du débat et ils ont été en quelque sorte
dans la discussion les porteurs de cette
revendication mais c'est une
revendication qui les dépassait
largement et qui était vraiment
qui traversait le milieu des onegers qui
est assez divers comme vous savez parce
que entre France Nature Environnement
Greenpeace et kit ONG comme ESF c'est
pas du tout les mêmes dynamiques pas du
tout alors est-ce que
pour faire écho à ce que vous est-ce que
ça posait un problème de
représentativité oui je comprends très
bien qu'on puisse
qu'on puisse poser la question
il y a d'ailleurs d'ailleurs c'est poser
la question de savoir comment on comment
on crée comment on sélectionnait le
collège des ONG vous voyez pour les
syndicats c'était facile on a les
syndicats on a les joules suspectent de
la de la de la négociation
syndicale mais pour les ONG comme on
l'avait jamais fait qui est-ce qu'on
invitait à la table du Grenelle il y
avait des ONG pour lesquels c'était
évident en France Nature Environnement
enfin pour moi c'est évident ça se
discute pas vous voyez il y en avait
d'autres
et bon en même temps vous savez
la légitimité
ça se crée dans la durée quoi il y a un
moment où il faut il y a un moment il y
a un moment où il faut bien commencer
commencer quelque part à partir du
moment où on voulait avoir un une remise
à plat une relance des politiques
environnementales de manière coopérative
on avait besoin d'avoir des partenaires
autour de la table on a pris des
partenaires qui nous ont semblé le plus
légitime est-ce qu'ils avaient le même
niveau le même historique et le même
niveau de représentation que des
organisations sociales représentatives
non mais est-ce qu'il y avait un
meilleur moyen de faire
merci merci pour ces aimants c'est c'est
intéressant parce que
c'est pas toujours simple à posteriori
de se remettre dans le contexte d'alors
c'est quand même un exercice de
contextualisation qui est pas toujours
évident et c'est vrai que c'est une
critique qui vient aujourd'hui
de la part des syndicats qui doivent
aujourd'hui démontrer leur
représentativité en vertu des lois qui
ont changé en 2010
c'est là que c'est c'est là que le
dialogue est différent c'est-à-dire que
avant 2010 la représentativité des
syndicats est-elle légale enfin elle
découlait d'un choix arbitraire du
gouvernement d'après-guerre et
finalement ils viennent poser
aujourd'hui les syndicats sur la table
cette discussion qui est pas
inintéressante en disant maintenant
qu'ils sont dans le tour de table
peut-être qu'il faudrait qu'il se pose
les mêmes questions que celles qui nous
ont été posées en 2010 à savoir comment
est-ce qu'on définit notre
présentativité
c'est une question très légitime ces
questions encore une fois au début quand
on crée le tour de table on invite les
gens on va pas commencer en leur donnant
il faut il fallait comment il fallait il
fallait faire un premier pas et on a
sélectionné comme on pouvait il y a eu
des débats encore une fois sur qui on
mettait dans le total on a sélectionné
comme on pouvait il y a des gens qui
vous diront pourquoi vous avez pris la
Fondation Nicolas Hulot c'est le star
system il y en a qui vous diront mais
pourquoi vous avez pris le SF ils sont
tout petits ouais c'est eux qui avaient
oui bon il fallait commencer après que
quelques années même là maintenant plus
de 10 ans après on pose la question de
de structurer ça et et d'avoir des
critères de légitimité un petit peu plus
transparent un petit peu plus net je
trouve ça absolument
normal légitime et même urgent
merci beaucoup j'en viens sur une
question plus sur le fond du du Grenelle
la succession d'auditions dans des
périodes de politiques successives et
assez intéressante c'est-à-dire que j'ai
le sentiment que tout le monde en
arrivant
à la préoccupation d'accélérer le
développement des éner on a auditionné
Lionel Jospin qui nous a dit quand je
suis arrivé c'était ma préoccupation
vous nous dites
bon nous on a fait le Grenelle on a
voulu doubler le développement des EnR
or hydraulique parce que tout le monde
dit toujours hors hydraulique puis on a
eu le pouvoir qui a succédé au vote qui
nous dit on est arrivé il y a rien qui
était fait il a fallu qu'on accélère le
développement des EnR et puis enfin on
vient de voter un texte pardi je crois
dont l'objectif est d'accélérer le
développement des ENR
non j'ai voté contre mais madame
et encore je peux vous dire ce que
j'entends à New York sur le
développement c'est pas fini et ça va
continuer pour longtemps
je vous en prie vous la doublez on
voulait doubler la part des EMR
hydraulique compris ce que je disais
c'est que le problème c'est que on
partait d'une base installée de NR qui
était essentiellement hydraulique donc
en fait il fallait plus que doubler
largement plus que doublé l'éolien et le
photovoltaïque pour doubler la part des
élèves vous comprenez quand on est
imaginez on est à 10% de je sais pas
combien 8% d'hydrauliques on veut passer
à 20% l'hydraulique on en fera peut-être
1% de plus c'est pas tellement plus ça
veut dire que en fait il faut multiplier
par 10 les EnR non hydraulique
c'est ça le calcul
si vous permettez moi
j'étais j'ai fait tout ce que je pouvais
pour accélérer le développement des
énergies renouvelables en les couplant
avec une politique industrielle ce qui a
été critiqué par certains à l'époque
parce que toute façon il y avait c'était
un fromage aussi par exemple le solaire
mais mais mais mais mais mais j'assume
complètement ce qu'on a fait sur le
sujet moi je trouve que ces politiques
elles doivent être menées elles sont
légitimes mais elles doivent être
couplées avec des politiques de l'emploi
des politiques industrielles des ça a
pas de sens une politique
environnementale c'est trop important
d'une certaine manière c'est trop
structurant c'est majeur ça ne peut pas
être découplé ça ne doit pas être
découplé des autres politiques
importantes du pays vous parlez dans
votre vie de votre commission de de
politique stratégique ça me semble tout
à fait bien et légitime de la même
manière la politique environnementale
elle doit être couplée avec une
politique industrielle une politique en
matière de l'emploi une politique
sociale on peut faire abstraction de
rien de tout ça et c'est un petit peu la
parfois
quand on se donne un objectif juste en
matière on va augmenter la part
d'énergie renouvelable machin on le fait
comment est-ce que est-ce que ça
bénéficie du développement d'une base
industrielle c'est pour ça que j'ai cité
dans mon propos liminaire l'éolien
offshore parce que je pense que c'est
vraiment quelque chose le cas on a
réussi à créer un embryon de base
industrielle et on a eu beaucoup plus de
mal sur d'autres d'autres énergies
renouvelables et par exemple se faire et
sur le solaire on a essayé encore une
fois avec les mêmes recettes que pour
l'éolienne Shore c'est à dire en fait
avec des bilans carbone avec
toutes les toutes les tous les trucs
pour pour contourner soyons clairs les
règles de l'OMC
et ça a marché au début nous appelloffre
il était bien je vous invite à les lire
c'était de la poésie
et puis ça c'est des faits dans le temps
oui moi j'ai pas je sais pas s'il y a eu
un manque de volonté politique pour en
avoir parlé avec des techniciens
d'administrations de en charge ils m'ont
dit aussi que la Commission avait été
beaucoup plus sévère beaucoup plus
[Musique]
elle avait elle avait été elle avait pas
fermé les yeux quoi contrairement à ce
qu'elle a fait sur l'éolien
merci beaucoup dans les vous soulignez
la place qu'avait l'enjeu de filière
industrielle dans les choix que vous
avez fait et proposer
quelle était la place
en 2008
de la sécurité d'approvisionnement dans
le débat public un sentiment que c'est
un sujet très contemporain du débat
énergétique mais qui ces dernières
années n'a peut-être pas été au cœur de
ce qui motivait le débat public autour
de ça je qu'elle était mémoire la place
de cette question là
vous avez dit très très justement
en parlant des syndicats et des ONG que
on peut relire on est dans des contextes
différents moments qui sont différents
et ça ça
jette quand même ça change quand même la
couleur d'un débat en 2008
il y avait pas de problème de
production on était on était on était
occidental
et donc
il se posait des questions sur l'avenir
mais finalement les derniers réacteurs
nucléaires
du programme dit
mes sphère
était
avait été mis en service en
2000 un ou deux c'était chose et si beau
donc c'est relativement récent vous
voyez c'est pas non plus
ancien et de toute façon en termes de
niveau de production
on avait un production qui était
excédentaire au regard de nos besoins et
d'ailleurs c'est plutôt une situation
qui pour quelques années c'est j'allais
dire c'est aggravé à gravé ou pas
aggraver enfin c'est c'est confirmé
c'est accru à cause de la crise
qui a qui a fait suite à la crise
financière de 2008 donc c'était pas il y
avait pas
il y avait pas un espèce de sentiment de
d'urgence on était on était vraiment
plus qu'en vivre dans le Grenelle le
premier sujet c'était l'efficacité
énergétique c'était de très loin devant
ce genre de ce genre de considération et
ça a duré pendant quelques années
de cette de cette manière là ça veut pas
dire qu'il y avait pas des débuts de
réflexion je vous ai dit par exemple on
a lancé la conception de la du cahier
des charges des visites décennales parce
qu'on savait que les visites décennales
allaient arriver on a lancé à ce
moment-là une réflexion qui a abouti
plus tard qui a abouti après mon départ
de mystère cela mise en place d'un
mécanisme de capacité
pour
chercher mais oui il y a deux choses
en matière d'énergie il y a
produire et puis il y a des moyens de
production qui sont plus ou moins
souples qui sont plus ou moins
pilotables donc le mécanisme de capacité
visait cette dernière dimension on était
conscient qui avait un
qu'on pouvait se retrouver en difficulté
en difficulté qui pouvaient qu'il
pouvait y avoir des problèmes disons de
pilotabilité et donc on a lancé une
réflexion qui a abouti par la suite
quelques années après je saurai pas vous
dire exactement quand vous avez sûrement
ça quelque part donc je dis pas qu'il y
avait pas des réflexions autour de je
précise d'ailleurs que que cette partie
là par exemple mécanis capacité relevait
pas de mes attributions à moi puisque
comme je disais en 2010 pour pour des
raisons j'ai pas développé mais bon la
la gestion la partie marché de l'énergie
et
je suis sur les grandes opérateurs de
l'énergie a été transféré à Bercy
pour quelle raison
[Musique]
il y avait eu des débats
pendant la campagne de 2016
sur
le
la politique en matière de
nucléaire
flamant en ville en ville le reste des
débats internes dans l'équipe de
campagne et j'avais une position
que je prétends plus informés
et qui du coup était plus modéré sur le
sujet
d'abord je trouvais qu'il fallait pas
précipiter les choses parce que je
trouvais que c'était pas complètement
mur je trouvais que les tensions à
l'intérieur de l'équipe nucléaire
française
devait être réglé avant enfin qui était
plus urgent les régler en fait que de
prendre des décisions de ce genre je
trouvais qu'il fallait
prendre s'imposer les décisions de ce
genre dans un contexte plus global qui
intégrale par exemple
l'utilisation de la chaleur fatale de
l'industrie nucléaire qui était qui a
jamais été valorisée et qui a bon et je
trouvais que la dimension du projet EPR
était peu cohérente avec les évolutions
du marché mondial de l'énergie c'est un
très gros très gros des acteurs très
centralisé un très gros réacteur très
centralisé ça correspond à certains
besoins mais là la dynamique de marché
elle est plutôt dans le sens des petits
réacteurs un très gros acteur très
centralisé ça veut dire aussi la
nécessité d'avoir des très grosses
lignes THT qui viennent avec des
problématiques spécifiques donc voilà
moi je trouvais que la question que la
question se posait qu'elle était
légitime j'étais pas formellement contre
mais je pensais qu'il fallait
résoudre d'autres problèmes avant ou en
tout cas en même temps et peut-être se
poser des questions un peu plus de
questions sur la dimension du
c'est une il y a eu
ça
je mets en parler mais ça peut être un
peu technique un peu
vous savez on a une centaine d'heures
d'auditions sur les sujets énergétiques
donc on arrive à comprendre tout
doucement
je mets pas en cause je n'ai pas encore
de compétences nucléaires c'est juste
que je sais pas si c'est je sais pas si
c'est vraiment dans le cœur de vos
sujets quoi c'est en gros
pourquoi faire un tellement gros
réacteur vous pouvez avoir
des raisons de
d'économie d'échelle mais
n'a pas prouver ouais par l'expérience
et vous tombez dans d'autres problèmes
qui sont des problèmes d'équilibre de
vos plaques énergétiques des problèmes
de
d'extraction de l'énergie par ligne à
très haute tension qu'en l'occurrence il
a fallu il a fallu construire est-ce que
c'est vraiment ça que le marché demande
alors vous aviez une partie du monde des
ingénieurs nucléaires qui disaient oui
mais ça vous permet aussi d'avoir un
niveau de sûreté supérieur et par
exemple le réacteur d'EPR il était conçu
pour que en cas de fusion du cœur le
corium ne traverse pas parce qu'en fait
vous aviez des nappes de béton et par
gravité le cœur fondu en fait ce serait
ce serait retombé sur la nappe de béton
il y avait des choses comme ça il y
avait il y avait pas mal de
je suis pas là pour trancher de toute
façon j'ai pas forcément toutes les
données du problème mais je trouvais que
ce débat
n'était pas complètement
qu'on n'avait pas été au bout de ce
débat en fait et qu'on s'apprêtait à
prendre une décision politique
sans avoir politique forte
qui était un petit peu prématuré au
regard de la maturité du sujet technique
quand je dis technique j'ai technique en
intégrant la dimension d'un marché de
compétitivité de parce que parce que la
question c'est pas seulement le
construire pour nous mais aussi le
construire pour un marché et qu'est-ce
que le marché appelait réclamait comme
taille de réacteur ben vous voyez en ce
moment on repart à nouveau des SMS
c'est peut-être une question qui qui
qu'on aurait dû creuser plus à l'époque
donc voilà donc pour ça pour dire que ça
c'était les opinions que j'avais exprimé
dans la campagne en domicile 2016
et je pense que ça participait du
redécoupage quand je suis arrivé en 2010
on a dit bon on lui donne tout mais
peut-être que le marché et la production
on va le on va le on va le rendre en
quelque sorte à Bercy c'est très
intéressant cet échange moi je pense
qu'on est pleinement dans le champ
d'exploration de de la commission bon
vous avez vous avez balayé finalement
les la question de la taille la question
des normes peut-être pas tout à fait
figée au lancement du chantier de l'EPR
la question de la bataille
structurelle et quasi institutionnelle
entre arriva et EDF
la question du du format est-ce que à
l'époque où le choix commencer le père a
été faite on aurait pu par exemple
choisir encore une fois sans refaire le
passé mais juste pour se poser dans le
contexte choisir de lancer par exemple
un ATM 1000 je crois que c'est comme ça
qui s'appelait réacteur derrière il va
le petit
pardon
les gens qui n'ont jamais existé
oui le problème
c'est que
il y a il y a
le nucléaire politique environnement la
politique énergétique c'est un sujet
très politique mais il y a des
fondements techniques
qu'il faut
maîtriser qui nécessite un certain
investissement vous voyez et moi je
pense que ça investissement
à l'époque
aurait pu être plus plus
dense
c'était pas une yes en audition ça a été
vécu comme ça
il y a des gens qui sont contre le
nucléaire il faut lancer sinon on perd
la compétence on y va le Pr est prêt on
dit oui on fonce
je
du coup quelque part EDF qui avait son
projet prêt voyez on a quelques sortes
profité pour que pour que pour que ce
soit pour que ce soit validé pour qu'il
y ait un oui et pour qu'on fonce il y
avait il y avait d'autres il y avait il
y avait des débats il y avait des débats
d'ingénierie du coup y compris et
d'ingénierie encore une fois à la
question du marché escapelmarchais qui
ont pas été menés à leur terme parce
qu'il y a eu le sentiment dans le monde
politique que c'était un marqueur
politique force qui était le vrai
d'ailleurs et dans le monde des
énergéticiens que c'était la fenêtre
politique pour obtenir le lancement et
même si c'était pas mûr c'était le
moment d'y aller et tout ça comme vous
le dites s'insérer dans le cadre d'un
débat au couteau entre EDF et Areva qui
qui facilitait pas le enfin qui polluait
énormément en fait le le
contexte de cette prise de décision donc
moi mon point de vue d'un point de vue
tel que je l'avais exprimé de manière
interne à la campagne c'était il faut
d'abord démêler le conflit EDF parce que
de toute façon lancé dans ce contexte là
c'est c'est se positionner pour l'échec
à l'exportation on va pas on va pas
pouvoir présenter un fourni ça va pas ça
va pas bien fonctionner il faut prendre
le temps de regarder quelles sont les
options technologiques quand j'ai les
options technologiques c'est c'est pas
pour moi il y avait il y avait quand
même une vraie questionnement sur la
taille du réacteur d'autant plus que
après moi au niveau ministériel j'ai dû
gérer la question de la THT et
oui il faut il faut une part de
production d'énergie centralisée comme
il faut une part de base dans un pays
qui aspire à avoir par exemple une
politique industrielle et avoir une
grande industrie c'est indispensable
mais
le très gros réacteur
à la périphérie
d'un
hexagone du réseau du de la plage du
réseau
ça veut dire en fait forcément une très
grosse voyez ça posait je trouve qu'il y
avait des questions qui qui aurait
mérité un petit peu plus de travaux et
de réflexion après honnêtement
honnêtement si on prend enfin si je
crois pas de recul et j'essaie de faire
abstraction de toute de toute l'émotion
de qui a entouré ça
des problèmes c'est que il y avait des
mouvements de balancier pour des mauvais
motifs politiques sur la politique
énergétique et donc il y avait la
crainte dans l'industrie nucléaire ou
dans tous ceux qui tout simplement
croyaient au nucléaire et j'en fais
partie il y avait la crainte que si la
décision était pas prise tout de suite
un jour il y aurait un mouvement de
balancier politique et on se retrouve
après une décision
strictement politique comme on l'avait
eue avec la fermeture de super Phénix ou
comme on l'a eu plus tard avec la Reine
Astrid et donc il y avait cette
inquiétude que comme il n'y a pas
suffisamment de consensus où il y a plus
comme il y a une époque de consensus
national autour d'une politique on n'a
pas vraiment le temps et donc il faut y
aller et donc je
comprends aussi je comprends mais je
connais la dynamique qui a abouti
à la à cette décision on aurait pu on
aurait pu attendre un ou deux ans et
avoir une réflexion un peu plus aboutie
sur certains sujets et puis surtout
démêler le problème EDF Areva avant de
lancer mais il faut voir qu'on est dans
un contexte dans lequel on avait
l'impression que
en gros à chaque fois que la gauche
revenait au pouvoir le PS s'intéresse
pas à l'écologie sous-traitée ouvert et
les verres avaient une seule demande qui
était
d'enfoncer un point de plus contre la
politique nucléaire donc très souvent en
fait contre la quatrième génération mais
après il y a eu la question Fessenheim
après et donc il y avait cette
inquiétude de ouais c'est la fenêtre
d'opportunité pour lancer les choses et
si on lance pas on sait pas ce qui se
passera dans le futur
au passage je trouve que cette
discussion devrait amener à une
réflexion c'est pas moi de lui dire ce
que de faire mais les politiques
énergétiques ça peut être que des ça a
besoin de stabilité donc d'ailleurs ça a
besoin d'un minimum de
d'accord
il faut que ça dépasse un petit peu les
partis politiques le mouvement de
balancier sur des sujets
d'investissement aussi long il amène
forcément à soit faire des bêtises dans
un sens moi je pense qu'on a fait des
bêtises sur la quatrième génération je
pense que la quatrième génération a été
victime d'accord politique parfois mal
informé
technologiquement et il peut amener à
faire des bêtises de l'autre sens au
sens de de la prise de décision
accélérée parce que justement on craint
ce mouvement de balancier le mouvement
de balancier sur des sujets aussi
stratégiques aussi structurant qui qui
s'inscrivent dans une durée aussi longue
il peut aboutir bien des des de mauvais
résultats
d'un côté comme de l'autre une mauvaise
résultat
merci beaucoup c'est vraiment très
intéressant et du coup je creuse un tout
petit peu vous disiez ça manquait on a
bien compris le cadre dans lequel se
prend cette décision vous dites
finalement le l'expertise des solutions
alternatives manquait un peu de
profondeur de densité d'ailleurs
employer le mot densité
d'où ça vient de justement de ce
mouvement de balancier du fait que
préalablement on est consacré moins
d'études
aux évolutions des technologies
nucléaires ou
moins de préoccupations au lancement de
nouveaux chantiers nucléaires parce que
on a le sentiment que la France a quand
même avec le CEA avec sa filière
industrielle un panel d'outils d'outils
développement d'industrialisation du
nucléaire mais vous dites finalement on
est le panel il ne conduit pas forcément
à des solutions technologiques
différentes et on a on n'a pas d'autre
choix que de prendre celle qui est
disponible à quoi vous expliquer ça
moi je pense que le conflit entre DF et
Areva à une immense part de
responsabilité là-dedans parce que comme
vous le soulignez en fait on a des
acteurs divers de très grande qualité
chacun dans lesquels il y avait il y
avait vraiment de la
et je pense aussi au CE1 à tout ce qui
est entre
tous les niveaux de la chaîne on avait
ce qu'il fallait pour pour prendre des
bonnes décisions très informées mais à
cette époque là le milieu était
complètement crispé autour du conflit
EDF Areva du coup d'ailleurs une partie
de l'expertise qui était plutôt dans le
monde de la recherche du CE1 était un
petit peu au croqueville sur même parce
qu'ils avaient pas envie en gros de se
retrouver les
otages de de
ce de cette bataille dans laquelle on
tira balle réel et donc alors qu'il y
aurait eu toute l'expertise tout ce
qu'il fallait pour mettre tout le monde
autour de la table et avoir une
réflexion véritablement structurée et
ben les acteurs se sont un peu
recroquevillés sur eux-mêmes
il y a pas eu vraiment de forum pour les
raisons que je disais parce qu'il y a
une espèce d'accélération politique de
crainte en fait que fenêtre politique
sur ferme un moment donc il y a pas eu
vraiment de forum il y a pas eu vraiment
le temps et puis il y a quand même eu
des des postures si vous voulez EPR
c'était le truc de DF Ada c'était le
truc d'un rêveur on avait des
compétences à la à la
dans le monde militaire on avait des
compétences qu'on aurait pu aussi
exploiter dans un cadre civil qui ont
pas vraiment été appelés dans la
discussion enfin il y avait vraiment je
sous optimale tout à l'heure moi je
pense que il y avait il y avait vraiment
tout ce qu'il fallait pour avoir un
débat de de meilleure qualité
que ce qui a eu et qui qui était pas
prête je vous dis moi j'ai pas j'ai pas
été associé
au fin mot de cette affaire là parce que
je me suis exprimé dans la campagne de
2007 à l'époque j'étais j'avais ma place
dans ces discussions pour des raisons
très accessoires qui étaient d'une part
que j'étais la seule à m'intéresser à
l'écologie dans mon parti donc j'étais
la spécialiste de l'écologie du parti
mais si vous voulez j'étais quand même
très très junior dans si simple et
l'autre raison c'est que j'étais
ingénieur et il y en a pas beaucoup dans
le monde politique et je trouve que
j'étais une ingénieur qui connaissait
bien le nucléaire parce que mon père
avait été le directeur de Framatome qui
avait vendu les centrales aux Chinois
donc je connaissais bien de l'intérieur
tout ce monde-là
chez machin je donc j'ai participé à ces
discussions cette manière là mais mais
après comme secrétaire d'État je me suis
pas du tout occupée de nucléaire je
m'occupais vraiment de la négociation de
Grenelle de l'environnement et je vous
dis quand je suis revenu comme une
ministre on a on a
j'ai pu été je n'ai pas été en charge de
ça j'ai été en charge de la sûreté
alors je change de sujet pour revenir un
peu au Grenelle le Grenelle introduit
des évolutions majeures dans dans la
perception qu'on a du réseau notamment
de distribution avec le fameux compteur
intelligent qui qui arrive à cette
occasion là
quelle est l'évaluation finalement qui
est faite à cette époque de la nécessité
d'injecter plus d'intelligence dans le
réseau tant de distribution que que de
transport
alors il y avait une
il y avait ça c'est une bonne question
complexe
il y avait l'idée que
cet élève et que notamment c'était
l'avenir d'un système
de réseau qui allait être
plus décentralisée en termes de pilotage
qui allait faire un meilleur place
aux consommateurs dans
dans une place qui soit moins passive en
quelque sorte et qui soit plus active il
y avait il y avait une vision en quelque
sorte de cette évolution là et puis de
l'autre côté il y avait des réticences
réticents sur la manière dont tout ça
allait être
mis en oeuvre réticence aussi dans
certains cas sur il y a eu un débat par
exemple sur les les ondes autour du
compteur il y avait il y avait d'autres
sujets en quelque sorte parasites qui
sont venus interférer
une des manières de mémoire dont on a
répondu à ça c'est que je crois que je
l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure dans le paysa
il y a eu de l'argent sur les réseaux
intelligents je crois les compteurs
intelligents en tout cas les smart grid
il y a eu il y a eu l'investissement en
recherche
peut-être en prototype franchement je me
souviens pas sur cette dimension là
et dernière question sur le Grenelle
est-ce que quelle était la place de la
réflexion vous étiez en charge
ensuite en tant que ministre de
l'écologie du volet minier la place de
l'enjeu stratégique sur les matériaux
critiques sur les métaux etc dont on
voit qu'ils sont dimensionnants en fait
dans la transition énergétique et
notamment l'électrification
franchement à l'époque le sujet était
embryonnaire donc ce genre de choses qui
ont été évoquées mais qui ont pas fait
pas fait l'objet de
politique ou de programme plus structuré
que ça en matière minière il y a eu
plusieurs il y a une décision qui a été
la décision d'arrêter le projet dit de
la montagne d'or en Guyane qui a été une
espèce de de décision en quelque sorte
préliminaires à aux discussions du
Grenelle ça faisait partie
en quelque sorte de lancement de la
négociation les ONG étaient très
opposées je pense avec raison à ce à ce
projet
mais
il y a rien eu
de très dans mon souvenir de très
structurés sur la question des métaux
rares et des choses c'était vraiment
maintenant on en parlait énormément ici
aussi aux États-Unis on en parle
énormément ça devient un enjeu
stratégique
identifié
conséquent avec d'ailleurs pas mal
d'investissements y compris privés il y
a un gros investissement qui vient
d'être annoncé aux États-Unis de 600
millions de dollars de mémoire dans une
un projet minier de lithium
dans le je crois que c'est l'ambiguest
donc pour développer en quelque sorte
ici une base nationale stratégique de
production de lithium donc il y a plein
de choses qui se passent aujourd'hui à
l'époque franchement c'était pas c'était
pas cent donc quand on parlait mine
c'était pour parler de projet comme la
montagne d'or et pour les houx par la
suite pour parler du code minier
plutôt pour le mettre en cohérence pour
essayer de mettre en cohérence avec les
dynamiques coopératives et la l'exigence
de transparence dans les politiques
publiques qui avaient été manifestées
lors du Grenoble merci beaucoup je vais
laisser la parole aux rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la ministre pour ces explications déjà
nombreuses
quelques questions préliminaires à
nouveau sur le la conception du Grenelle
peut-être quand même une seconde sur la
question des syndicats parce que des ONG
et de leur rapport par rapport au
syndicat en fait je reprends le terme
que vous utilisez tout à l'heure en
disant qu'il s'agissait de d'une
question politique enfin d'un choix de
considération et donc de faire oeuvre
enfin de faire un acte nouveau de prise
en compte des ONG dans le débat public
et de les mettre au même rang que
d'autres organisations ce qui peut
effectivement poser des questions par la
suite de représentativité quand vous
dites que c'est politique en fait
pardonnez-moi loin de moi l'idée de
faire de la politique ici mais c'est
bien le candidat Nicolas Sarkozy qui
dans une volonté d'ouverture voulait
montrer que l'écologie pouvait être une
politique de droite et donc c'était une
manière de légitime de légitimer
l'écologie de droite en allant discuter
avec des organisations non
gouvernementales qui étaient classées
politiquement à gauche même si elles
étaient écologistes et que cette
distinction n'a pas forcément de sens
c'est ça l'idée qui a derrière le
Grenelle de l'environnement quand vous
êtes dans l'équipe de campagne du
président et que vous avez lu du
candidat et vous avez l'idée de faire le
Grenelle de l'environnement c'est
d'aller chercher un symbole écologiste
de gauche pour le mettre autour de la
table et de prendre un revers
l'adversaire politique pendant la
campagne
alors on peut le voir comme ça
évidemment diversité marrant votre
phrase pour dire loin de moi l'idée de
faire de la politique j'espère même que
vous en faites de la politique parce que
si on en fait pas l'Assemblée nationale
je vous dirais que
on peut le voir comme ça mais il y a
aussi un objectif plus noble qui est que
ça a servi à débloquer des postures y
compris d'ailleurs des postures
administratives pas seulement des
postures politiques au sens des parties
qui aboutissaient à des situations de
blocage sur
un tas de sujets de politique et mesure
concrètement qu'est-ce qui se passait
vous aviez un ministère de l'écologie
qui était
petit qui était faible
offert le truc il y avait pas de corps
d'état au ministère de l'écologie en
tant que tel les autres mystères chacun
leur corps d'état à l'écologie n'avait
pas
qui était
un truc que moi j'avais découvert que je
travaille
un ingénieur qui un ingénieur d'état
dans les corps d'état qui allait dans un
des autres ministères il avait des
primes qui étaient liés à son corps au
ministère de l'écologie on avait
quasiment pas donc
on s'étonnait après que ce soit une
administration que les autres vous voyez
contester en disant qu'elle était
militante ouais elle était militante
vous savez celui qui décidait d'aller
faire sa carrière au ministère de
l'écologie il décidait d'emblée qu'il
aurait tout au long de sa carrière
quelque chose comme 30% de moins que
celui qui a été allé dans un agriculture
au ministère de oui ce que je veux dire
maintenant ça a changé parce que c'est
c'est tout ça tout ça a été à l'époque
au moment du Grenelle on a fait un gros
travail en quelques heures de réformes
et de réorganisation des administrations
qui évidemment a été moins visible et
moins grand public mais qui a
complètement transformé ça mais avant ça
on avait un ministère de l'écologie qui
était qui était petit qui était faible
politiquement
administrativement je veux dire faible
administrativement
qui qui se concevait du coup aussi
beaucoup comme étant en situation et pas
à tort parce que c'était la réalité en
situation conflictuelle avec les autres
donc il y avait un conflit les conflits
perpétuel avec le mystère de
l'agriculture sur les pesticides sur la
politique de jachère tout ce que vous
pouvez imaginer il y en avait à l'époque
avec mystère de l'équipement sur sur les
routes surtout la politique de reportage
en fait on avait avec avec
Bercy sur tout ce qui était fils qui a
été environnemental donc toutes les
politiques environnementales étaient
conflictuelles et pas seulement
conflictuel au niveau politique elle
s'est constituée au niveau administratif
et
le Grenelle de l'Environnement
a servi en fait à casser ça et il a eu
encore une fois c'était pas connu grand
public mais il a eu un volet
administratif considérable c'est-à-dire
qu'on a réuni
dans le même ministère des gens qui
avons été au ministère de l'Équipement
ministère du Logement ministère de
l'écologie
pour certains qui étaient qui avaient
qui avait été qui avait tenté le
ministère de l'Agriculture c'était
c'était ça a été un mouvement de
majeur de pour faire tomber en quelque
sorte des espèces de de murs entre
administration qui qui était autant de
autant de blocages organisé donc oui je
comprends je comprends je comprends ce
que vous dites et et bien sûr rien de
tout ça n'est innocent politiquement
mais mais
il y avait il y avait il y avait quand
même des objectifs plus élevés que ça
aussi
je vous remercie et une question enfin
une plutôt une réflexion que je vous
partage pour avoir votre avis sur la
question de l'exclusion du nucléaire du
Grenelle parce que c'est une situation
finalement qu'on retrouve pas tel quel
puisque le Grenelle est assez unique en
son genre mais qu'on retrouve dans
d'autres moments de la période qu'on
étudie l'idée qu'on sort le nucléaire du
débat public ou parlementaire ou parce
qu'il écrit spa ou parce que la décision
est déjà prise est-ce que c'est quand
même pas un peu paradoxal de se
retrouver dans cette situation où
finalement parce que c'est trop crispan
ou clivant politiquement et socialement
on en parle pas ce qui condamne ou bien
ne pas prendre de décision ou bien
apprendre des décisions qui ne
bénéficient pas de la même lumière
politique médiatique parlementaire
est-ce que d'une certaine manière dans
le cas du Grenelle de l'environnement on
peut imaginer que c'était pour ne pas
parasiter les débats sur les autres
sujets ou pour ne pas mettre en
difficulté le nucléaire face à des ONG
qui étaient majoritairement
anti-nucléaire mais est-ce qu'il y a pas
une dimension paradoxal de vouloir pour
le préserver j'imagine dans le cas
d'espèces l'exclure du débat et du coup
perdre en crédibilité et en légitimité
démocratique
je comprends ce que vous dites j'ai
d'abord relever que le nucléaire a pas
été le seul à être exclu des débat enfin
exclut
il faut s'entendre sur ce qu'on appelle
exclu le nucléaire et c'est un fait de
la politique énergétique française et
personnelle simplement on n'a pas dans
les groupes de travail on n'a pas eu un
groupe de travail nucléaire on a on n'a
pas mis en négociation et en discussion
le sujet le nucléaire a pas été le seul
dans ce cas là ça a été le cas aussi par
exemple de la chasse
en termes d'implication
environnementales macro la chasse n'a
quand même pas tout à fait le même
statut que ce qui produit 80% de notre
électricité
participe tout à fait ce que vous dites
sur le fait qu'on en
que le
qui a un sentiment qu'on laisse se
développer un sentiment
qui a quelque chose de de secret de
différents
et que c'est un petit peu
c'est un petit peu dommage moi je pense
que il faudrait qu'on réussisse le
nucléaire à sortir des catégories de
pensées quasiment religieuse
des deux côtés
de
[Musique]
de l'échiquier c'est à dire que il y en
a qui sont contre de manière où je
trouve parfois
pas complètement étayé mais vous avez
aussi des choses qui sont de l'ordre de
la foi de côté de ceux qui sont pour
y compris de manière
pas complètement étayée ou qui qui
mériterait plus de débats sur les
différentes options je trouve qu'on est
on est devenu un petit peu avec le temps
un petit peu religieux
sur ce sujet avec des arguments
définitifs du genre de Gaulle la fait
donc c'est bien enfin vous voyez
bon
on peut être un peu plus sophistiqué que
ça peut-être collectivement
nationalement sur un sujet comme vous le
signalez aussi important
sur merci en effet rien j'ai
l'impression
donc c'est bien
pardon je continue je continue alors là
sur les différents
peut-être sur le contenu du Grenelle
parce que c'est une partie ils avaient
raison vous avez raison le souligner en
propos liminaire qui est forcément un
peu moins abordé dans nos débats mais
qui n'est pas moins importantes qui est
à la fois la maîtrise de la demande la
capacité à être sobre et efficace du
point de vue énergétique
peut-être vous demander moins comment
les engagements du Grenelle en la
matière en matière d'efficacité de
sobriété de rénovation par exemple ont
été pris mais que la manière dont vous
avez eu le sentiment qui sont été
pris en compte par les acteurs une fois
les principaux outils déployés dans les
années qui qui ont suivi et la manière
dont vous analysez ensuite ce qu'on
pourrait considérer comme un je sais pas
si le mot retard et sévère dans les 15
dernières années mais en tout cas une
insuffisante progression par rapport au
gisements d'économie d'énergie en la
matière
cela mise en oeuvre du Grenelle il faut
il y a une espèce de très grande variété
d'instruments de mise en oeuvre de
Grenelle donc je sais pas si on peut
porter un jugement comme ça global parce
que il y avait des choses qui étaient
strictement législatives d'autres qui
étaient législatives et réglementaires
il y avait des choses qui étaient nées
réglementaires et qui consistait à
lancer des appels à projets et donc il
dépendait en fait de la rapidité avec
laquelle administration mettait en œuvre
les appels à projets il y avait des
choses qui étaient de l'ordre des
accords volontaires avec les acteurs de
la filière il y avait une dimension
budgétaire parce qu'il y avait des
choses qui avaient besoin de financement
donc
évidemment tout ça a eu des vitesses de
mise en oeuvre à des cinétique
différentes ce qui est ce qui est assez
normal moi vous allez dire que je suis
un peu obsédé mais comme je suis la
seule à être j'ai l'impression parfois
obsédé par ça il faut bien qu'il y en
ait un je pense que le manque de
couplage avec la politique industrielle
a été un facteur majeur de
ralentissement et quand je dis le
ralentissement de de de Stop and Go
parce que
si on sur les sujets sur lesquels on
réussissait on a réussi à lancer une
base industrielle
chaque effort de politique publique
participaient de la compétitivité
nationale
éventuellement de l'aménagement du
territoire dans certains cas parce que
une partie de cette base industrielle a
pu se faire dans des territoires qui
étaient à redynamisés et donc et d'une
politique de l'emploi et donc quelque
part c'était des c'était
il y avait pas il y avait pas de débat
si vous voulez il y avait pas de points
bloquant sur les sujets sur lesquels les
objectifs environnementaux
ne n'était pas accompagné
clairement d'une de bénéfice en matière
d'emploi ou de compétitivité ou en tout
cas pas à hauteur de l'investissement et
ben c'était plus
c'était plus contentieux ou en tout cas
c'était forcément
plus tributaire des
conditions
macroéc on se retrouvait à pouvoir le
faire quand on avait de l'argent et à
ralentir quand on en avait plus
l'intérêt de coupler je sais pas pour la
beauté du geste de coupler avec des
politiques industrielles et des
politiques en matière de l'emploi et des
politiques en matière d'aménagement du
territoire c'est que c'est comme ça que
ça marche dans la durée c'est comme ça
qu'on crée une dynamique positive de
laquelle tous les acteurs sont pour
puisque le bénéfice est évident et je
pense que ça
manquait sur
certaines des énergies renouvelables et
en particulier sur solaire et sur les
oignons l'éolien terrestre j'entends oui
je pense que l'éolien l'éolien offshore
et on voit pas forcément beaucoup dans
les chiffres aujourd'hui parce que ça a
été une énergie qu'on a développé plus
tardivement
mais mais mais c'est une exception à ce
problème que je soulignais au passage
il y a la question de la politique des
réseaux de chaleur et de la et de la et
d'utilisation et du développement de la
chaleur renouvelable on en a on a un peu
parlé chez ici d'en parler un peu dans
mon dans mon propos liminaire je trouve
que c'est un sujet qui a été peu ou
insuffisamment traité en France et c'est
notamment une des
un des regrets je trouve de la politique
de la politique de DF la politique
nucléaire alors je sais qu'il y a des
questions techniques autour de ça mais
vous savez une centrale nucléaire ça
produit beaucoup de chaleur fatale et
d'ailleurs un âge intérêt d'avoir des
plus petits réacteurs que des gros
réacteurs c'est que vous vous avez votre
chaleur et plus décentralisée que quand
vous avez un gros réacteur vous
comprenez Flamanville je connais flamand
ville je connais bien le département de
la Manche comme disait que c'est beau
mais c'est loin et donc votre base
industrielle locale autour de
Flamanville est réduite
si vous avez des petits réacteurs qui
sont
et qui sont un peu mieux répartis la
question de savoir ce que vous faites de
la chaleur fatale de l'énergie de la
production nucléaire et peut-être un peu
plus pertinente en effet que tout
simplement quand tout ça se passe à
Flamanville
j'en fais pas un sujet majeur et je suis
conscient que je viens débat avec des
des ingénieurs plus plus techniciens que
moi que c'est un sujet qui est pas
complètement qui est pas complètement
simple mais mais je voulais le dire pour
mémoire parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'on en parle peu dans votre commission
question l'utilisation la chaleur et de
la chaleur renouvelable vous savez une
grande part on parle de production
d'énergie en ce moment on est dans
l'électrification mais une grande part
de la production de la consommation
d'énergie n'est pas forcément électrique
et notamment en matière industrielle on
consomme énormément de chaleur donc on
n'est pas obligé de tout faire passer
par des électrons il y a des manières du
point de vue thermodynamique moins du
point de vue du cycle énergétique je
veux dire
plus
plus plus plus
accueil à moins de gâchis il y a moins
de pertes en ligne dans le cycle
thermodynamique de de produire de
l'énergie ou de consommer de l'énergie
ça devant scène une de mes questions
futures mais vous avez largement répondu
je
reviens sur la sur le ce que vous venez
de dire sur le couplage enfin entre
politique industriel et et objectif
environnementaux avant de passer au
point sur les énergies renouvelables
juste un point à nouveau en lien avec le
Grenelle est-ce que ce que vous dites
s'applique par exemple à la question la
rénovation thermique est-ce que ce que
vous dites en creux c'est que c'est
important d'avoir des objectifs
environnementaux des objectifs
d'économie d'énergie de développer des
outils enfin j'allais dire des outils
incitatifs pour le consommateur vous
avez mis en place des mesures fiscales
crédit d'impôt emprunto 0 etc mais
est-ce que ce que vous dites s'applique
à la politique industrielle au sens de
du développement de la filière des
compétences et si oui est-ce que vous
vous avez eu le sentiment que lorsque
vous étiez au responsabilité cette
partie là qui était assurée j'imagine
par le ministre en charge de l'emploi ou
en charge de l'Industrie et par la suite
que cette dynamique là a été
suffisamment portée pour que la
rénovation thermique puisse s'effectuer
en réalité alors absolument la
rénovation thermique était une des
politiques identifiées comme étant
gagnant de gagnants de gagnante gagnante
en matière environnementale parce que
vous
avez un bénéfice de lutte contre le
changement climatique
conséquences quand même une grande part
de la de la de la de la
production de la production de gâchis
parce qu'il y a du gâchis dans la dans
la
dans l'isolation ou dans le manque
d'isolation gagnante aussi du point de
vue du particulier ou d'ailleurs de la
collectivité ou enfin de quiconque paye
ses factures parce qu'en fait vous avez
des horizons de rentabilité qui sont un
peu long pour les particuliers mais qui
sont néanmoins avérées
[Musique]
investissement et en combien d'années il
faudrait pouvoir le récupérer en
fonction de ce que sont les acteurs et
propriétaires m'enfu en tout cas c'est
gagnant de ce côté là aussi et
absolument gagnante du point de vue de
l'emploi parce que c'est de l'emploi
local et donc c'est un des secteurs sur
lesquels on a lancé très vite d'abord
des politiques de formation donc des
filières de de
d'accompagnement d'apprentissage de et
ce qui était important c'est en a lancé
aussi des politiques de certification
des acteurs pour que les gens se passent
pas arnaquer parce que l'un des
problèmes si vous voulez qu'on a eu avec
le Grenelle c'est que
le Grenelle c'était comme les routiers
disons plutôt ou 20 ans plus tôt c'était
sympa et donc tout le monde se mettait
les tickets Grenelle partout
c'était hier c'était drôle les autres
ministères voulaient chacun leur
Grenelle chacun voulait son Grenelle
mais c'était vrai aussi dans le monde de
l'entreprise on avait lancé quelque
chose c'était simplement c'est bien mais
mais toutes les petites les petites PME
chacun essayait de surfer en quelque
sorte sur la vague et donc on avait mis
en place des politiques de certification
et puis des politiques d'accompagnement
local par l'ADEME pour être sûr que les
travaux qui étaient faits étaient des
travaux de qualité et que les gens se
faisaient pas avoir éleuré en quelque
sorte par des choses qui s'appelaient
Grenelle et qui en fait était pas de
qualité mais oui ça a été un des sujets
d'emblée identifiés comme étant porteurs
d'emploi et porteurs d'emploi dans les
territoires c'est très local
rapporteur que maintenant ne fait plus
de Grenelle on fait des Ségur tout va
bien
c'est une question postale monsieur le
président
c'est une question postale
toujours sur cette question couplage
avec l'industrie vous en avez parlé déjà
mais si vous voulez bien revenir dessus
un instant sur le vous l'avez bien
expliqué pour l'éolien offshore
peut-être revenir sur l'éolien terrestre
et sur le photovoltaïque avec l'autopsie
de ce qui n'a pas fonctionné ou de ce
qui était insuffisant vous avez évoqué
les appels d'offres la capacité à à
localiser la production en tout cas
inciter à localiser la production est-ce
que vous avez d'autres d'autres éléments
qui permettraient de d'expliquer le
l'échec relatif pour être pour être pas
trop sévère en la matière
d'abord le sujet éolien one Shore et
solaire les sujets sont différents pour
moi l'éolien hunshore il y a une base
industrielle européenne simplement et
pas chez nous et donc si vous voulez
c'était vraiment on est dans un cadre
européen
la le lancement de notre politique de
développement néoliane Shore en France
était décalés par rapport à ce qui se
faisait en Allemagne ce qui se faisait
dans les pays nordiques ils avaient la
base industrielle nos volumes du cours
présentaient une part relativement
faible du volume de marché c'était bien
difficile lorsqu'on texte si vous voulez
de lancer une une base industrielle
nationale
donc c'était c'était un sujet qui était
lié à la maturité d'une industrie qui
part ailleurs
avait trouvé à se développer en Europe
donc c'était c'était pour le coup un
sujet différent du solaire parce que le
solaire le problème c'est qu'il y avait
eu par le passé des embryons
d'industrie européenne il y avait eu des
travaux de recherche notamment les CE1
vous aviez de la recherche solaire
dans les années je crois 70 il y avait
il y avait eu des choses de qualité trop
tôt une certaine manière
mais la base industrielle ce qu'il en
restait a été en train de était était en
train de
vivotait ou ne se développait pas bien
et en fait de plus en plus c'était en
train de se passer en Chine et donc on
était dans une situation dans laquelle
visuellement par politiquement en
atteignait les objectifs parce qu'en
fait on était en train d'augmenter
la quantité de solaire installée mais
quand vous regardiez de près avec quoi
on l'augmenter en proportion c'était de
plus en plus des panneaux chinois et
donc on finançait sur des engagements
de
multi annuels des engagements très
longue durée qui seraient payés par le
consommateur d'électricité nationale ont
financé des champs solaires qui pour une
faible partie bénéficiaire comme ça on
spote à l'emploi local parce qu'en fait
il allait avoir un peu d'installation
qui aurait peut-être un peu de
maintenance et puis un jour il y aura
peut-être un peu de démantèlement s'il a
été bien prévu mais pour l'essentiel en
fait était de l'import et financer
directement l'industrie chinoise donc
oui on faisait du chiffre en termes de
panneaux mais
vous avez pensé que j'ai pensé que
j'étais marquée par le travail aux
États-Unis et que et que et que je
partage un peu de leur obsession sur la
bataille commerciale avec chinois mais
enfin quand même je trouve pas
complètement légitime si vous voulez que
consommateur d'électricité français
s'engage à payer pour 10 ou pour 20 ans
sur sa facture d'électricité
les les
usines de production de panneaux en
Chine c'était pas c'était pas bien donc
ça a été mal vécu d'ailleurs c'est pas
par hasard d'ailleurs ça avait été ça
avait été préparé et puis et puis et
puis ça a été actionné quand j'ai repris
la responsabilité du ministère mais mais
je l'assume la totale responsabilité on
a fait un moratoire on n'a pas fait un
truc rétroactif contrairement à ce qu'on
fait certains autres qui d'ailleurs ont
été condamnés on a fait un moratoire
évidemment ça a été très mal vécu et je
le comprends très bien vous aviez des
installations locales qui malgré tout
c'est un peu d'emploi local en instant
mais on a mis un coup d'arrêt y compris
pour des raisons financières c'est vrai
mais pas que pour des raisons
financières parce que on n'était pas
contents de la manière dont dont ça se
déployait industriellement et on a
essayé de remonter des politiques de
soutien qui étaient d'abord elles
étaient plus sophistiquées en matière du
genre de solaire qu'on faisait et on
faisait pas tous essayer de faire du
soleil
innovant ce qu'on appelait innovant et
pourquoi on faisait ça comme ça parce
que ça permettait d'avoir des
spécifications qu'on a par ailleurs
renforcé avec des bilans carbone du
panneau bas carbone des choses comme ça
d'avoir des spécifications qui nous
permettaient de soutenir l'émergence
d'une filière nationale ou européenne ça
un peu marcher au début le problème
c'est que c'est vraiment des choses qui
doivent se développer dans la durée et
assez vite si vous regardez ces appels
d'offres et ben un certain nombre des
spécifications qu'on avait essayé
d'introduire qui était pas très
différente de ce qu'on a fait pour
l'éolien en mer l'éolien en mer on
disait
on veut on veut que les entreprises
emploient
d'apprentis tout ça c'est des façons si
vous voulez de se débrouiller pour que
ce soit une base industrielle locale
donc c'était pas très différent ce qu'on
mettait dans les appels d'offres le
problème c'est que c'est progressivement
on a vu partie ces choses-là moi je me
suis demandé quand j'ai dû partir je
vous dis j'étais plus aux affaires si
c'était
pour accélérer en quelque sorte pour
baisser les prix et pour faire du
chiffre sur le mégawatt installé pour en
avoir parlé avec
des
responsables de mon ancienne
administration il semble aussi que la
Commission européenne et
était plus regardante
que sur l'éolien en mer elle a un peu
fermé les yeux sur l'éolien en mer pour
les motifs que je vous disais parce que
c'est vrai que c'est une industrie
différente on peut argumenter et elle
n'a pas fait sur le solaire
une dernière question sur les énergies
renouvelables j'allais dire oui je peux
vous dire un truc juste
les Américains font sur une faction
réduction act on aimerait quand même de
temps en temps que la Commission
européenne soit un petit peu plus
vous voyez enfin le libre-échange à
concurrence tout ça c'est super moi
aussi j'ai fait des cours d'économie
mais
vous regardez donc je le mets dans ce
moment parce que je m'occupe
d'investissement dans les technologies
vertes aux États-Unis je peux vous en
parler je peux vous faire une incidence
370 milliards
370 milliards entièrement financés parce
qu'en fait une flèche une réduction
actes c'est 700 milliards de recettes
dont ils vont dépenser 370 milliards sur
les technologies vertes le reste c'est à
désendetter l'état donc déjà en plus
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
autofinancé c'est pas un truc vous savez
qu'on vote en disant on augmentera les
exercices sur le tabac et sur
et sur l'alcool évidemment on demande
jamais le truc est vraiment est vraiment
financer plus que financer puis 370
milliards vous réalisez le Grenelle on
avait quelques milliards ici ou là 370
milliards comme j'aurais dit c'est comme
c'est comme pour les guerres en tout cas
la première et la seconde guerre
mondiale ils arrivent tard les
Américains mais mais ils font des trucs
ils font les trucs de manière solide
quoi et quand vous ouvrez la boîte et
vous regardez comment sont dépenser les
370 milliards vous avez des critères de
localisation et de développement d'une
base industrielle locale qui sont
solides par exemple vous avez un des
outils majeurs
type de communauté que ce soit produit
au niveau national pour telle proportion
c'est et c'est explicite c'est pas des
trucs comme mes appels d'offres on était
obligés de contourner voyez et de dire à
oui mais on va faire un bilan carbone
des panneaux pour ne pas dire on
voudrait pas les panneaux chinois on
vous les panneaux européens on était
obligé de faire des trucs comme ça là
ils font pas ça hein ici le panneau il
est pas américain vous aurez pas le même
niveau de crédit d'impôt et la
différence elle est elle est solide
voilà je trouve que je trouve que
parfois ça agace
merci
une dernière question donc sur les
énergies renouvelables après là j'allais
dire dans le dans le la séquence logique
après l'industrialisation enfin la phase
industrielle là qu'il y a la capacité ou
l'acceptabilité de leurs implantations
et donc j'imagine que comme secrétaire
d'État en charge de l'écologie puis
comme ministre de l'écologie vous avez
eu fort à faire comme vos prédécesseurs
et vos successeurs pour rendre ces
installations plus acceptables quel est
la loi qu'on a que nous avons voté
récemment qui succède à d'autres lois
pour favoriser simplifier rendre plus
acceptable l'installation de source
d'énergie renouvelables sur le
territoire la teste à nouveau qu'on est
probablement pas tout à fait arrivé au
bout du du problème qu'est-ce que vous
avez vécu à l'époque en termes de
d'acceptabilité d'implantation des
panneaux d'éoliens terrestres
essentiellement à l'époque et quel leçon
vous en tirer pour la suite et pour
notre capacité à en réalité installer
cette quantité cette capacité de
production
qu'on aspire à installer quel que soit
les scénarios en tout cas de manière
beaucoup plus importante qu'auparavant
bon moi j'ai vécu comme ministre ce que
ce que chacun peut bien imaginer c'est à
dire que
grosso modo tout le monde était d'accord
pour dire que le développement des
énergies renouvelables c'était bien et
quand il s'agissait des avoir au fond du
jardin personne y compris des gens qui
étaient officiellement très favorables
n'étaient pour chacun trouver des
arguments pour que ce soit pas au fond
de son jardin parfois parce que
ce que je comprends parce que parce que
parce que parce qu'il y avait voilà ça
c'est un des meilleurs paysages et c'est
vrai que c'est pas c'est moi la tridéal
partout et il y a des choses pas
forcément qui ont été faites parfois
aussi parce que même si
il y avait l'idée que c'était pas
possible pour les gens il y a cette peur
que ça fasse perdre de la valeur
[Musique]
ou bien et qui sont là quels qu'ils
soient même si on n'est pas soi-même
forcément très sensible il y a cette
inquiétude que que ça ait des
conséquences
patrimoniales je vous dirai ma
conclusion de tous ces débats ça a été
c'est pas le bon c'est pas facile j'ai
pas de baguette magique mais il y a
trois critères
à suivre le premier c'est minimaliser
l'impact les paquets 3 éoliennes ici et
là
non quoi enfin
il y a des
on peut pas faire comme si on peut pas
faire comme si ça avait pas d'impact
faire semblant que c'est faire semblant
que tout le monde trouve sabot et c'est
pas vrai en fait c'est juste c'est juste
pas vrai donc il y a une
le zonage la minimisation d'impact c'est
quelque chose de d'important
la deuxième c'est que c'est légitime
d'avoir un partage de
de bénéfices il faut pas que ça se
retrouve qu'on se retrouve dans une
situation dans laquelle on achète les
populations donc il faut réussir dans la
mise en oeuvre des politiques à la fois
faire les choses de manière juste et en
même temps de manière découplée sinon
tout le monde y perd y compris en
dignité
et au passage c'est vrai sur l'éolien
c'est vrai sur sur beaucoup de choses en
matière de politique publique politique
environnementale en tout cas quand on a
fait par exemple le Parc amazonien en
Guyane
on a mis une taxe
sur de l'exploitation offshore qui
allait financer
une partie
du parc moi je suis je suis pas opposé
par principe pour dire c'est pas posé
par principe agent de choses là il faut
il faut pas il faut pas que ce il faut
que ce soit fait d'une manière qui qui
n'engage pas les acteurs dans un dans
une espèce de
négociation tordu la dernière chose
c'est la transparence
je fais référence à ce qu'on a fait sur
le gazochisme mais on est quand même
dans un monde dans ce cas certains
certaines
procédures d'attribution des
autorisations alors c'était vrai surtout
dans le Code Minier parce que dans tout
ce qui atteint les paysages c'est moins
le cas et et il y a quand même la
procédure plus ouverte et certains vous
diront que sont des procédures qui font
plus de plus de part à la à la
contestation mais enfin c'est bien que
les procédures soient claires et
établi sinon
on laisse place à des contentieux qui
traînent qui traînent et personne et
personne n'en profite je suis bien
consciente en vous disant tout ça que je
pose des principes qui sont pas
forcément simples à appliquer et
d'ailleurs j'ai pas trouvé que c'était
une partie simple de l'exercice
ministériel
mais enfin il y avait il y a rien de
pire pour moi que les situations dans
laquelle on avait l'impression que
l'accord local avait été acheté et dans
des conditions qui étaient
peu transparente
je vous remercie et de trois dernières
questions sur la 4e génération sur le
question des déchets et la quatrième
génération d'abord peut-être simplement
je suis pas sûr d'avoir compris vous
avez l'air d'avoir mis sur le même plan
l'arrêt super Phénix c'est celui
d'Astrid sauf
erreur super Phénix c'était un
démonstrateur en fonctionnement pour
lequel l'investissement initial avait
été fait et qui était en cours de
fonctionnement et si vous faites
référence à 2019 c'est la fin des études
et la décision de ne pas construire
de démonstrateur
je suis d'accord je comprends bien je
l'ai mise sur le même plan parce que
pour moi l'un et l'autre procédait d'un
accord politique
dont je suis pas certain ou un cas comme
dans l'autre qu'il ait été pris sur
certains qui n'a pas été complètement
pris sur les bases techniques
en tout cas c'est mon point de vue je
peux je comprends qu'on puisse en avoir
un différent mais il me semble que dans
les deux cas il y a une part politique
prépondérante dans cette décision je
pense si je peux aller un peu plus loin
on revient sur ce qu'on disait la
nécessité sur la politique du nucléaire
d'avoir une
attaquer la quatrième génération
à tort ou à raison c'était vu dans
certains milieux
vers comme attaquer
nucléaire à son talon d'Achille parce
que quelque part indirectement c'était
attaqué sur la question des déchets
je comprends raisonnement
je sais pas à quel point c'est c'est
juste ou pas juste mais voilà
dans ce cas là faut être sans faut être
sans
ça le système à la pensée il faut être
son naïveté donc quand on accepte
d'arrêter super Phénix ou qu'on renonce
à aller plus loin
sur Astrid on accepte de rentrer dans
cette logique là je trouve en tout cas
la question d'être posée autrement que
dans le cadre d'un accord politique vous
savez bien comment ils sont les accords
politiques dans les
notamment en marche des campagnes
présidentielles enfin j'étais par
définition pas dans
les les discussions sur l'arête super
Phénix enfin je doute qui est beaucoup
considération technique mais on croyait
pas
c'est pas la vie de Monsieur Jospin mais
nous nous
juste un mot quand même on a arrêté
super Phoenix mais comme on avait arrêté
superhénix et qu'on avait quand même
besoin d'eux on a prolongé Phoenix
c'est quoi la cohérence
c'était justement comme c'est comme
Osiris on a arrêté Osiris et après on
s'est rendu compte qu'on avait un
problème de recherche et donc on s'est
dit on m'a balancer enfin balancer non
c'était c'était
mais on s'est rendu compte on s'est mis
dans les prolongations et puis après
une question justement sur Phoenix enfin
sur l'enchaînement de la fin de Phoenix
et puisque il me semble que c'était soit
responsabilité en tout cas vous étiez au
fonction le lancement de du projet
Astrid par la signature de la convention
sur le projet Astrid et une des
questions qu'on a pu se poser au moment
de l'arrêt super Phénix et puis du
prolongement de Phoenix c'est la
capacité à capitaliser sur les
connaissances alors c'est pas exactement
c'était pas exactement votre votre à vos
attribution mais je pense que vous avez
vous avez peut-être un éclairage à
apporter sur le le comment dirais-je
l'orientation qui était
qui avait en tête le gouvernement de
l'époque au moment de signer la
convention
d'Astrid c'était bien d'aller au bout
c'est à dire de faire les études
préliminaires et ensuite de construire
un démonstrateur dans l'idée de
d'être capable de maîtriser
la quatrième génération du point de vue
expérimental de la recherche et du
fonctionnement
de recherche
non il y a
[Musique]
ou
Areva et EDF sont entrés dans des
tensions dont on a parlé le CE1 c'est un
de mon point de vue un tout petit peu et
je comprends bien pourquoi un tout petit
peu rétracté mais à l'origine il y avait
une dynamique dans le secteur de
nucléaire qui qui circulait qui était
beaucoup plus fluide que ça et notamment
oui le CEA faisait de la recherche mais
enfin le CEA
était quand même un lieu en quelque
sorte de capitalisation de l'expérience
nucléaire
le CEA était présent
participaient à des c'est une recherche
très appliquée quand même vous savez et
donc quand on parle de faire Astrid
ça participe aussi de tout le débat qui
avait à l'époque et qui d'ailleurs a
participé au lancement Flamanville de
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour maintenir
une une
compétence d'ingénierie en matière de
nucléaire alors je suis bien consciente
que c'est pas le même type
d'ingénierie d'aller construire des
réacteurs et d'aller faire du recteur
mais quand même il y avait il y avait il
y avait derrière une logique
des logiques qui des correspondances si
vous voulez c'était pas un système dans
lequel le CEA était dans la recherche
pure et fondamentale et EDF et Areva
aurait été dans
la production c'était beaucoup plus
fluide et circulant entre tout ça et
d'ailleurs je peux vous en donner un une
preuve enfin oui par c'est qu'au moment
l'accident de Fukushima on a eu un
difficulté qu'on a eu c'est que les
Japonais ont coupé toutes les
communications on n'arrivait pas à
savoir ce qui se passait il
s'était
donc on n'avait pas d'informations enfin
c'était quand même assez c'était c'était
angoissant à plusieurs titres et le
canot qu'on a trouvé le canal marchait
plus si vous voulez en fait on pouvait
pas appeler l'homologue ça marchait pas
le canal qu'on vous pouvez c'est par le
milieu de la recherche et par des gens
du CE1 qui avaient travaillé avec des
Japonais sur des réacteurs japonais qui
avaient des relations qui avaient et
donc on a réussi à avoir par ce biais là
des informations sur ce qui se passe
c'est dans la centrale donc voyez c'est
bien la preuve que c'est pas c'est pas
un truc dans lequel il y a d'un côté la
recherche avec des chercheurs en labo et
de l'autre côté non c'est plus fluide
que ça entre le milieu de la production
et milieu de la recherche
merci et une dernière question sur le
rapport Roussely qui est remis en juin
2010 et qui contient un certain nombre
de préconisations certaines qui sont qui
ont été visiblement appliqués comme
comme sur SIO mais il y a aussi des
recommandations qui portent sur
l'intérêt l'urgence de d'accélérer le
soutien à la prolongation des réacteurs
nucléaires y compris je lis à 60 ans a
sur tes constantes voire davantage
comment est-ce que est-ce que d'abord
vous êtes destinataire du rapport est-ce
que vous avez des échanges et comment
est-ce que vous recevez cette
préconisation alors qu'on en est pas
encore là dans les réflexions et y
compris dans les visites décennales et
est-ce qu'il y a des mesures qui sont
mises en place ou des discussions avec
la SN qui sont qui sont entamées pour
anticiper justement ce cap des 60 ans
alors plusieurs choses
j'allais dire ça me dit rien mais c'est
normal parce que s'il a été remis en
juin 2010 c'était avant que je sois
nommé ministre
j'ai été nommé ministre je suis revenu
en voyant que j'étais secrétaire d'État
puis
à la suite de quelques péripéties sur
les OGM
je suis allé
voir du côté du numérique et de la
planification ce qui s'y passait et je
suis revenu en novembre 2010 donc le
rapport aussi il m'a pas été remis à moi
je clique sur un
une expression que vous avez utilisée
qui assure tes constantes puisque comme
je crois on en a parlé plutôt une des
particularités enfin des principes de la
politique nationale en matière de sûreté
c'est justement que la sûreté n'est pas
constante elle doit progresser à mesure
des progrès technologiques et c'est une
différence par exemple avec la doctrine
de la N qui est l'agence en charge ici
aux États-Unis pardon je montrais ici
parce que c'est la 43e à New York
donc le a sur tes constantes en fait et
pour moi un peu un peu un peu mystérieux
parce que justement c'est c'est pas le
c'est pas le principe ce qui est certain
et je peux vous aider à travers des
quelques conciliations sur Fessenheim
ici
on savait que
il y avait un enjeu
et on parlait de la prolongation du parc
ça fait pas de doute j'ai lancé
la le
l'élaboration du cahier des charges pour
les visites des scénales
on parlait de la nécessité de les
de l'effhasé
voilà le principe des villes décennales
c'est qu'il fallait qu'elle il fallait
qu'elle puisse s'élo en lui visiter
Sénats c'est très
on parlait de choses comme les bénéfices
et inconvénients d'avoir un parc qui est
très standardisé le bénéfice c'est que
vous avez un effet de série
l'inconvénient c'est que si jamais vous
avez une malfaçon vous avez aussi un
effet de serrer sur la malfaçon donc on
parlait de choses comme ça et c'est
évidemment ça les conséquences sur la
sur la vie décennale parce que si vous
trouvez un problème ou un type de
travaux très lourd à devoir faire et on
parlait aussi des particularités de
certains sites soit en termes de
localisation géographique des sites qui
auraient été plus sensibles à
au risque sismiques par exemple
des sites qui auraient été plus
sensibles au risque de perte
d'approvisionnement en eau
ou des réacteurs qui pour des raisons
d'ailleurs que je connais pas bien alors
même que le parc était très standardisé
il y avait quand même quoi 332 réacteurs
de 900 mégawatts
et puis et puis la série 1300 les seuls
qui étaient vraiment différents c'était
les N4 parce que et encore parce que les
commandes étaient digitalisées mais
bon la conception était quand même très
transcendée on parlait aussi de
certaines particularités de certains
sites et notamment du site de Fessenheim
un des problèmes affessenheim il y avait
un problème que tout le monde peut
comprendre qui était quelle est la
quelle sera la source d'eau alternative
si jamais si jamais si jamais on mando
mais ça c'est des sujets locaux en fait
la question se pose dans toutes les
centrales c'est qu'elles sont quels sont
les les
ressources successives et les ressources
de secours en matière d'eau a fait cela
il y avait un sujet particulier qui je
sais pas pourquoi la
ce qu'on appelle le radier qui est en
quelque sorte plancher en béton de la
centrale était plus fin qu'ailleurs
alors ça a l'air de rien mais
l'épaisseur du radier commande la
cinétique de l'accident enfin la
cinétique de l'accident mais
comment la cinétique du passage du coeur
fondu en cas d'accident dans
le sous-sol et en l'occurrence dans la
nappe phréatique
et donc quand on a parlé je souligne ça
parce qu'en fait la question se posait
au moment des visites décennales au
moment du lancement de l'appel d'offres
de évidemment on fait un cahier des
charges
standard mais enfin on a aussi en tête
la spécificité de tel ou telle centrale
et compte tenu du fait que dans la
doctrine française la sûreté nucléaire
ne se fait pas assurer constante mais se
fait avec
acquisition au fil du progrès
technologique de d'amélioration il était
question si on avait fait une visite
décennale et si on avait voulu prolonger
Fessenheim de poser la question de
l'épaississement du radier pour
éviter ce problème particulier le
Fessenheim et du risque de la de la de
la cinétique d'un accident nucléaire
quand les visites décennales ont été
lancées finalement je crois que le jeu
était fait
EDF pensait que c'était c'était fini
professionnelle et mécanécision avait
été prise je me souviens pas du détail
des différents mais du coup de mémoire
ils n'ont pas intégré ça s'est fait
après mon départ ils n'ont pas intégré
Fessenheim dans les villes décennales et
donc on saura pas combien ça aurait
coûté et si même ça aurait été
techniquement possible d'épaissir leur a
dit
mais c'est pour dire que bon le principe
c'est que l'autorité sur tes nucléaire
est indépendante mais évidemment
évidemment tout ça a des conséquences
potentielles sur des choix politiques
énergétiques qui ne relèvent pas de
l'autorité sur tes nucléaire mais qui
évidemment l'informe
simplement pour vous préciser que le
radier de la centrale de Fessenheim a
été épaissi en 2013
ouais mais au moment de la visite
décennale il aurait fallu le réépaissir
parce qu'il était pas à la hauteur de ce
qu'on aurait réclamé pour avoir un
niveau qui se rapprochait de la sûreté
la troisième génération je crois je vais
pas vous dire de bêtises mais il me
semble bien
est-ce que vous aviez un sujet qui était
alors de mémoire vous avez un sujet la
seule chose que vous pouvez pas changer
sur une centrale c'est la cuve
et vous pouvez épaissir le radier
de ce que vous avez comme espace en
dessous de la cuve et je crois que vous
pouvez pas je crois que vous pouviez pas
aller aussi loin qu'il aurait fallu une
histoire comme ça après écouter je suis
pas je suis pas ingénieur de la sûreté
merci beaucoup madame la ministre j'ai
fini une question mais simplement pour
le j'allais dire fort de record comme on
dit de votre côté de l'écran là parce
que vous avez cliqué sur l'expression à
sûreté constante en fait c'est
l'intitulé de la recommandation du
rapport Roussely je cite soutenir
l'extension de fonctionnement des
centrales à 60 ans virgule assureté
constante donc je pense que c'est plus
une imprécision et qui ne s'agissait pas
d'une remise en cause du choix normatif
français quand même c'est curieux comme
titre parce que parce que c'est vrai que
c'est c'est contradictoire avec la
doctrine
je sais pas j'en ai pas parlé avec lui
je vous dis j'étais pas j'étais pas
encore revenue merci beaucoup en tout
cas
monsieur alors on va passer la parole au
député qui sont présents monsieur l'aîné
merci monsieur le Président j'ai trois
groupes de questions je peux prendre
trois fois la parole ce sera peut-être
plus clair voilà ouais ouais oui oui
alors la première d'abord merci pour
vous pour vos réponses d'ailleurs
certaines de mes questions vont vous
reprendre certaines de vos réponses mais
peut-être pour essayer d'avoir quelques
précisions d'abord sur les énergies
renouvelables vous avez déjà répondu en
partie à ce qui expliquait le retard qui
a été qualifié tout à l'heure de de
relatif pour rester poli de la France
dans le développement des EnR je partage
vos
interrogations enfin vos sur le fait que
le manque de filière industrielle en
France participe du retard qu'on a
accumulé en particulier sur le
photovoltaïque mais aussi sur l'éolien
est-ce qu'il y a pas aussi peut-être
l'obsession du marché de vouloir
systématiquement passer par le marché
est-ce que je qualifie moi en tant que
député elle est finie pèse de demain
visible du marché alors que précisément
pour le nucléaire on a toujours
avec l'État et d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
il a été dit que sur Flamanville
peut-être
on s'était passé d'une consultation
publique parlementaire mais en vérité
dans toute l'histoire du nucléaire on
sait largement passé du débat
parlementaire et du débat public voilà
l'électricité c'est un système ça a été
rappelé la dernière fois quand on a
auditionné les quatre représentants
syndicaux d'EDF c'est un système il
semble que pour moi ça justifie que ce
soit l'état qui prennent la main et que
ce soit pas laissé à la main du marché y
compris pour le développement des ENR
alors je veux dire que je
je peux menti écho à ce que vous dites
en disant que
le marché seul
va pas construire une politique
énergétique ce qui veut pas dire qu'il a
pas sa place bien au contraire
mais il y a des choses qui ne fait pas
par exemple
la programmation long terme le marché
fait de l'optimisation et d'optimisation
à court terme et je veux dire c'est bien
et c'est et c'est important dans des
dans des systèmes interconnectés et qui
puissent y avoir de l'optimisation à
court terme mais il va pas faire de la
programmation
à long terme pour moi une politique
énergétique de bien bien équilibré
c'est une politique énergétique dans
laquelle d'abord l'état fait de la
programmation à long terme y compris par
exemple sur les sujets de recherche qui
n'ont pas de bibibition mais plus que ça
sur sur des sujets de réseau des
suggestions des sujets comme on l'avait
je vous ai dit un peu plus tôt qu'on
avait lancé une réflexion sur les
questions capacitaires l'équilibre entre
la base et le reste les capacités
pilotables ce genre de choses là en fait
le marché
ne
prend pas en compte toutes ces
dimensions donc on a besoin d'une part
de programmation de l'État ce qu'il faut
c'est trouver des systèmes dans lesquels
à l'intérieur de cette programmation
nécessaire
on laisse suffisamment de liberté aux
acteurs locaux et industriels parce que
c'est quand même comme ça que ça marche
bien et
on fait effet de levier
sur de l'argent privé pour que ce soit
avant tout des capitaux privés qui sont
investis parce que c'est les sommes
tellement conséquentes la transition
énergétique que si vous voulez faire ça
sur le budget de l'État
d'abord vous allez probablement faire
les choses de manière très sous
optimales mais surtout vous n'y
arriverez pas donc trouver des moyens
comme on l'a fait par exemple je parlais
des appels d'offres vous voyez quand on
a mis en place les appels d'offres sur
l'éolien offshore bon on définit un
cadre qui est un cadre d'État c'est on
définit des zonages on lance des appels
d'offres sur les zones on y met des
critères
pas du tout innocent pour développer une
base industrielle mais enfin les appels
d'offres ils sont à destination
d'acteurs privés et c'est les acteurs
privés qui répondent et qui derrière
construisent pour moi pour moi c'est ça
une politique équilibrée je précise que
pour que ça marche bien il faut qu'il y
ait de la visibilité
et il faut qu'il y ait vraiment de la
enfin que les acteurs privés se sentent
suffisamment à l'aise pour pouvoir
investir dans le long terme ce qui à mon
avis est une des forces ce qui est en
train d'être fait aux États-Unis avec
une fashion réduction actes je vous
donne juste un exemple sur l'hydrogène
ils font un dispositif dans lequel un
producteur d'hydrogène vert aura 3
dollars par kilo
je vous remercie bonjour pour votre
raisonnement quand même sur les masses
monétaires l'état reprend vient de
racheter pour quelques milliards les
dernières actions de DF qui n'avaient
pas EDF et endetté à hauteur de 60
milliards je crois que le grand carénage
est estimé entre 100 et 150 milliards
donc je note qu'on se pose un peu moins
de questions pour dépenser sur cette
partie là mais c'est pas grave deuxième
question en si je ne dis pas de bêtises
en le 3 janvier 2012
la SN vous a remis un rapport je crois
que c'est à votre demande et suite à
Fukushima et en particulier sur la
question de la sous-traitance et mettant
en balance la question de la
sous-traitance et celle de la sûreté des
installations alors est-ce que vous avez
quelques précisions à nous apporter là
dessus
deuxième chose on sait que les
sous-traitants reçoivent 80% des doses
qui sont reçues par les agents qui
interviennent sur les centrales est-ce
que c'est pas ça la vraie raison du fait
que on les laisse à l'extérieur d'EDF et
la troisième question est-ce que vous
pensez que ce serait pas une bonne idée
précisément de les reprendre en interne
pour garder cette compétence parce qu'à
force d'externaliser on se retrouve avec
EDF qui ne sait plus faire toute une
partie des manœuvres qui a à faire quand
il faut changer le combustible etc on
sait que 80 % des événements majeurs
sont imputables à une erreur humaine
voilà est-ce qu'il y a pas un intérêt à
reprendre en interne c'est ses
compétences là
c'est une très bonne question c'est en
effet un des sujets qui a été
qui a été sauvé après Fukushima et
finalement où sont les compétences et en
cas de crise en fait à qui à qui on fait
appel et qui et qui
est mais qui qui est disponible qui est
là qui sait qui connaît les lieux qui et
ça posait la question de la continuité
la sous-traitance c'est ça en fait les
problèmes de la sous-traitance c'est que
vous maîtrisez pas
dans la durée qui vient
forcément sur le sur le site
il y a deux sujets différents pour moi
dans ce que vous soulevez comme question
et dans ce qui dans ce qui dans ce débat
il y a la question de suivi des
personnels il s'assurer que aux
personnes nées exposées à aucun moment
ni au fil de sa vie professionnelle à
des doses supérieures à ce qui autorisé
et ça c'est quelque chose qui est
exigible aussi bien de l'opérateur que
des sous-traitants c'est à dire que
c'est pas parce qu'on fait appel à un
sous-traitant qu'on peut
évidemment c'est pas conçu comme ça il
soit au palettes et à la question des
compétences
qui est donc une question différente
parce que même si vous vous assurez que
aucun sous-traitant n'est exposé
à plus que les deux autorisées la
question la continuité des sous des
compétences et évidemment pas la même si
si l'opérateur et si le si le si le
personnel est
titulaire ou est appelé à des missions
variées il avait été demandé
un de mémoire dans ce dans ce dans ce
dans ce débat il avait été demandé à EDF
de faire une revue de compétences et une
revue de la question de la
sous-traitance au titre de la continuité
et de la construction des compétences je
pourrai pas vous dire ce qui n'en est
devenu parce que comme vous le soulignez
le rapport il a été remis janvier 2012
et moi j'ai quitté le ministère le 14
février 2012 donc je je pourrai pas vous
dire avec plus de précision qu'elle
suite EDF a donné au rapport mais il y
avait
il faut vraiment séparer parce qu'il
faudrait pas qu'on laisse dans l'idée
que sous prétexte que c'est un
sous-traitant il peut être exposé à plus
de radiations c'est pas vrai c'est pas
fait comme ça c'est pas construit comme
ça mais ça veut pas dire que ça pose pas
un problème de compétence et la question
des compétences
devaient être étudié par EDF pour
éventuellement remettre en cause
certains dispositifs de sous-traitance
je saurais pas vous dire qu'elle suite a
été donné à ça
je vous remercie donc dernière question
puisque vous étiez en poste à l'époque
de Fukushima et en charge de la sûreté
du nucléaire est-ce que vous pensez
qu'un tel accident est exclu en France
on sait que plusieurs de nos centrales
sont situés en bord de mer ou en zone
inondable et d'ailleurs
Branly est construit sur un polder et là
est à l'étude l'idée de faire deux
nouveaux EPR à penlis à Gravelines on
veut en construire également deux
nouveaux sur un site entièrement
offshore du coup question suivante
est-ce bien raisonnable finalement de de
relancer la construction de nouvelles
centrales avec Flamanville qui est
toujours pas terminé bon vous avez déjà
largement répondu sur Flamanville mais
un prototype de EP R2 qui pour l'instant
est quand même pas vraiment au point la
question des déchets à l'heure actuelle
pour s'occuper des déchets les
installations qu'on a à la fois autour
des réacteurs et avec Landry avec six
géo pas du tout démantionner pour
accueillir de nouveaux déchets qui
viendraient de nouvelles centrales et
enfin il y a quand même le réchauffement
climatique qui qui s'installe pour un
petit moment même si on essaye de lutter
contre la question de la sécheresse et
du réchauffement des cours d'eau voilà
ma question c'est ouais est-ce que un
accident tel que vous kushima serait
possible en France et est-ce bien
raisonnable de relancer la construction
de nouveaux réacteurs quand on sait tout
ça
alors
est-ce qu'un accident
serait possible en France j'ai envie de
vous dire
probablement pas exactement le même mais
quelque part
c'est c'est c'est
pas c'est pas le sujet
on a entendu ici ou là des propos sur le
fait qu'il allait pas avoir de tsunami
dans le rein et que donc Fessenheim
n'était pas en situation c'est vrai
mais les leçons de Fukushima c'est pas
juste est-ce qu'on peut avoir un tsunami
les leçons de Fukushima ce que j'ai
essayé d'esquisser c'est
un accident dans lequel en fait il y a
une série de sur accident
qui aboutissent à avoir un site
nucléaire qui est coupé
du monde et et en situation
potentiellement d'emballement
c'est-à-dire
un événement naturel qui est un tsunami
qui noie le dispositif de
refroidissement et derrière un
emballement parce que il y a pas
suffisamment de dispositifs autonomes
de de
refroidissement et aider
des problèmes
connexes non mineurs comme la mise en
danger des mises en fragilités des
piscines parce qu'il y a un problème de
résistance des piscines à cette
situation la mise en danger des
opérateurs sur le site parce qu'il y a
un problème de protection des opérateurs
en situation d'action solide etc ce que
je veux dire c'est que c'est pas parce
qu'on risque pas un tsunami ici ou là
vous aurez pas de tsunami à
Saint-Laurent-des-Eaux que il y a pas
des des
qu'on n'a pas à apprendre qu'il y a pas
des conséquences à tirer de l'accident
de Fukushima et d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'on a essayé de faire dans les
évaluations complémentaires de sûreté on
s'est pas posé enfin on sait pas
seulement posé la question de savoir si
l'accident est exactement en tant que
tel était réplicable parce que oui c'est
et puis d'ailleurs c'est pas comme ça
que ça arrive jamais ça se répète jamais
exactement la même manière et ça veut
pas dire qu'il faut pas tirer des des
enseignements donc on a essayé quand
même de tirer des enseignements à
travers
tout ce que j'ai dit les diesels de
secours beaucoup mieux
d'abord doubler et non sensible enfin
non sensibot tremblements de terre aux
tornades etc beaucoup mieux
protégés mais aussi des choses comme les
forces d'action
rapidement nucléaires projetable sur le
site pour ne pas se retrouver en fait
avec juste une une dépendance de ceux
qui sont à des choses de ce jour
[Musique]
est-ce que est-ce que c'est parfait et
est-ce qu'on peut faire mieux
tous les systèmes de production
énergétique on leur inconvénients et
celui là on a comme d'autres vous avez
cité la question des déchets pardon de
vous dire mais il y a une petite
conséquence à je sais pas si c'est votre
cas personnel mais
je crois que c'est celui de votre partie
à c'est tellement battu contre la
quatrième génération et à pointer du
doigt aujourd'hui le problème des
déchets parce que je serai la première à
dire que quand on utilise le terme
recyclage pour parler de la filière des
déchets on ment parce qu'en fait
aujourd'hui il y a pas un recyclage la
filière est pas bouclée mais enfin
c'était aussi l'enjeu de tous ces
travaux de recherche et donc à un moment
il faut bien les avancer et trouver des
solutions ça faisait partie du du
du projet initial mais je trouve que
c'est quelque chose qui doit être
poursuivi et qui doit être voilà qui
doit être avancé sur la question du
réchauffement climatique je comprends
très bien le problème que vous soulevez
oui une centrale ça doit être refroidie
je voudrais juste souligner parce que je
trouve que parfois il y a une ambiguïté
là-dessus que la quantité d'eau
nécessaire pour refroidir et pour
produire n'est pas la même alors il en
faut pour refroidir et un des problèmes
à Fukushima c'est pas ça qui est plus
doux par définition il y en avait mais
c'est que les pompes étaient noyées donc
si vous voulez il faut non seulement
avoir de l'eau mais avoir un système qui
pompe et qui permet de refroidir mais la
quantité d'eau nécessaire pour refroidir
un réacteur qu'on a mis à l'arrêt en
situation de crise ou d'urgence
c'est-à-dire on a fait tomber les bars
on l'a mis à l'arrêt la réaction
s'arrête il va falloir continuer à le
refroidir mais c'est juste du
refroidissement de quelque chose qui a
été arrêté et la quantité d'eau
nécessaire pour pouvoir fonctionner à
plein dans la durée
elle est elle est pas la même et et en
fait quand on quand on pose la question
en termes de changement climatique qui
est un vrai sujet on doit intégrer ça
aussi c'est à dire que le changement
climatique dans la cas de de situation
non-réacteurs n'est en général par un
problème de sûreté il peut être un
problème de compétitivité au sens de de
production dans la durée parce qu'il y a
des moments où on peut être obligé de
ralentir parce qu'en effet il y a un
problème d'approvisionnement en eau
merci monsieur Dubois
monsieur le Président merci Madame la
Ministre donc je voudrais revenir sur le
phénomène de vous l'avez très bien
expliqué d'abord vous remercier de
toutes votre toute la transparence toute
la sincérité avec laquelle vous avez
vous m'avez tout au moins pour ma part
bien éclairé sur sur vos fonctions les
décisions prises et je voudrais revenir
sur ce que vous a dit qui me paraît
extrêmement important notamment
donc sur on le voit bien en matière de
nucléaire on est dans des temps longs
des temps qui sont avec des de la
recherche de la nouvelle technologie et
ces temps qui sont beaucoup plus longs
que les temps politiques et notamment
les alternances politiques et on voit
bien que ben on voit le dernier exemple
au 31 août 2019 l'arrêt du programme
Astrid qui
arrête donc ce programme de recherche
sur cette expliquée par lors de la
dernière audition le directeur de
cabinet d'Edouard Philippe qui nous dit
que avec la complexité de leur majorité
politique et un coût qu'il jugeait trop
important donc et on voit bien que là on
a une réflexion qui est prise et une
décision qui est prise plus par
Bercy vous avez parlé tout à l'heure et
ça me semble important d'avoir des
cloisonné certains ministères pour faire
avancer des choses et on se retrouve au
Bercy prend une décision de de d'arrêter
un programme de recherche et de et
finalement peut-être
à long terme de de faire que ça sera
compliqué de de trouver une souveraineté
et notamment après sur sur les les
matériaux certaines et
l'approvisionnement la résilience donc
qu'est-ce que vous le voyez maintenant
vous êtes on va dire dans sur un autre
continent ou et on voit que suite à ça
on a déjà une problématique de quel est
le bon mix il va falloir sûrement et je
voudrais peut-être vous pourriez nous
nous donner votre avis sur ce mix
qu'elle est déjà ce décider sur un mix
et pouvoir donc lancer des programmes
par une loi peut-être programme donc et
un temps long en rapport au nucléaire et
ensuite on sent bien qu'il y a pas de
souveraineté notamment énergétique sans
un appui fort de l'État même si on voit
bien et vous l'avez dit je suis en
accord avec ça que l'État n'a plus
suffisamment d'argent aujourd'hui pour
assurer cette souveraineté il faut être
intelligent et essayer de d'aller
chercher donc des investisseurs qui
permettent de rester aussi dans dans
cette souveraineté cette résilience
nationale on sent qu'il y a un besoin
d'un engagement national et d'état sauf
que on est au milieu d'un marché public
de l'électricité donc européen donc
comment allier ces choses là également
entre
et on le voit
en ce début d'année où on est presque à
perdre notre souveraineté économique sur
un coût de l'électricité qui est bien
trop élevée avec une obligation de
marché européen et voilà comment allier
les deux et peut-être aussi comment
aujourd'hui sortir provisoirement de
cette obligation de marché de
tarification européenne et perdre
au-delà de notre souveraineté
énergétique notre souveraineté
économique merci de votre réponse
mais merci autre question monsieur le
député qui qui n'est pas facile si vous
permettez
d'abord je peux dire que je suis
d'accord avec vous avec avec la
nécessité sur la nécessité d'inscrire
les politiques énergétiques dans le
temps long et des inscrire au-delà
l'alternance je vous dis moi je pense
que la super Phénix comme la Reine
Astrid était quelque chose qui a été
dicté par des accords ou des équilibres
politiques
et quand en quelque sorte en effet
miroir la décision accélère sur
Flamanville qu'on aurait pu travailler
plus
et aussi une réaction de on le fait
maintenant parce que la fenêtre c'est
maintenant et donc dans tous les cas
on bénéficierait tous collectivement
d'avoir des réflexions sur ce sujet qui
sont moins crispés et qui débou sur des
choix collectifs
partager et inscrit dans la durée un
choix collectif
au passage ça c'est ça peut être quelque
chose sur lequel on n'est pas d'accord
en fait il y a il y a un compromis on se
met d'accord sur un mix on se met
d'accord sur un mix qui est pas
forcément celui l'un ou l'autre aurait
choisi mais enfin voilà c'est un c'est
comme la vie en collectivité et là on
s'est je trouve qu'on s'enferme sur les
politiques énergétiques
sur des choses
idéologiques qui sont particulièrement
dommageables sur un sujet qui est celui
du temps long et qui intègre par
ailleurs des dimensions
technologiques aussi compliquées et par
ailleurs évolutif sur la question du bon
mix du coup j'ai envie de vous dire pour
moi le bon mix c'est celui sur lequel on
réussirait à être d'accord
collectivement dans la durée et à tenir
le cap donc je vais pas dire que j'ai la
vérité révélée parce que parce que je
viens de vous dire que c'est
probablement quelque chose qui ne mettra
personne qui mettrait personne
totalement
voilà qui serait un compromis mais
l'intérêt c'est que ce sera un compromis
qu'on pourrait dans la durée moi à titre
personnel ce que je pousserais en
cohérence et ce que je l'ai dit
maintenant c'est pour moi le bon mix
c'est celui qui permet aussi de soutenir
et qui est soutenu par une base
industrielle nationale forte qui fait sa
place à des objectifs stratégiques qui
évidemment a son importance en matière
de nucléaire concrètement le bon mix il
a une base nucléaire pour moi y compris
une base de recherche qui permet de
tenir sa place dans un concert
international dans lequel la France a
toujours eu une place singulière et ce
serait vraiment dommage qu'elle le perde
et puis ce sont d'autres énergies et des
énergies renouvelables et de préférence
un accent sur celle sur lesquelles on
peut développer de l'emploi et on peut
mener une politique industrielle locale
qui qui participent de notre
compétitivité c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai tellement insisté sur
l'éolien en mer vous avez cité le
problème européen franchement on en a
peu parlé
j'ai vraiment l'impression que sur les
politiques énergétiques on s'est un
petit peu laissé manger
sur certains choix par les Allemands et
comme les Allemands ont fait des choix
énergétiques et ont une structure de
production qui en conséquence qui est à
l'origine était déjà assez différente de
la nôtre et qui n'a fait que diverger et
bien voilà les structures de production
divergentes ça fait des intérêts
divergents et
si on croit comme moi qu'ils ont mieux
défendu leurs intérêts ça fait une
pénalisation pour les intérêts nationaux
c'est c'est très clair
la place ici mais ils ont c'est pas
c'est pas comme si les Allemands en
matière énergétique avaient fait que des
choix formidables et je vous parle pas
que du nucléaire par exemple il y a
quelques années il s'est posé la
question de savoir si on allait
développer des terminaux mécaniers en
Allemagne
je crois qu'il y a eu une pression des
Russes mais c'est pas de pression enfin
bon il y a eu des débats et en gros les
Russes ont expliqué et promis qu'avec
North stream 2 ce serait pas nécessaire
bah on voit bien le résultat aujourd'hui
et on est heureux en France d'avoir plus
de capacités de ce côté-là et par
ailleurs des bonnes capacités de
stockage stratégique donc ce que je veux
dire c'est que il y a pas une bonne ou
une politique une bonne ou mauvaise
politique c'est les politiques assez
différentes et en l'occurrence serait
bien des critiques le parfum soulager un
peu sur la nôtre ces derniers temps il y
aurait bien des critiques à faire sur la
politique énergétique allemande mais il
y a un problème qui est que c'est des
politiques qui sont très différentes qui
ont plutôt eu pour sa diverger et si on
considère comme moi que le dispositif
européen a plutôt penché sur ces sujets
du côté de l'intérêt ou en tout cas de
l'oreille
prêté ou l'attention prêtée à la
structure de production allemande et ben
ça dit bien en creux que qu'on est un
peu perdu
merci beaucoup madame la ministre qu'on
a fait le tour des questions de notre
commission d'enquête a va vous poser
merci beaucoup pour votre disponibilité
depuis
New York on a vu progressivement le jour
se lever derrière vous
donc
la journée de travail commence la neutre
est déjà bien entamée merci beaucoup
pour votre disponibilité pour la
précision de vos réponses et pour les
éclairages que vous avez apporté à nos
travaux parlementaires
le le votre apport sera rendu public et
de voir quand est-ce qu'il sera
disponible est-ce qu'il sera disponible
tout simplement à ce qui va
il fera accessible ou ça va être quelque
chose on espère que donc c'est une
commission d'enquête donc les travaux de
notre rapporteur seront soumis à la
commission d'enquête qui décidera de sa
publicité tout début avril
formellement pour respecter le cadre
juridique voyez je vois sourire je vois
sourire le rapporteur
j'espère produire un rapport qui passera
au moins le cap de la publication sinon
écoutez on me demande pas mon vote mais
mais mais mais il irait néanmoins dans
le sens de la publication et j'espère
beaucoup pouvoir le lien
[Musique]
je me permettrai d'évoquer votre soutien
au moment du vote alors madame je vous
remercie
merci à vous et bonne journée à vous
au revoir